it's looking really ominous especially given
that he's down on time this is the magnus
carlson squeeze um wow hicaro's playing
in front of hundreds of people imagine
being in his shoes right now i mean up
by four games well i can resign yeah
carl knows it it started with 16 players and
it all came down to one man magnus carlson
this is a pretty great matchup i know people
love hikaru nakamura hikaru is the favorite
for a reason he's the beast an absolute monster
it has been hecaro's speech his championship
this 2018 hiker nakamura the overall 1c
takes it home in the speeches championship
obviously this is a rematch of last year's scc
final what a finish by the way i mean that's
been the story of the match the kara nakamura
has just kind of out swindled out tricked and
out calculated wesley in the critical moment up
dude that's a nice move wesley's shaking his head
ikaro wins upon he's going to draw
this game i can't believe it which
happened unbelievable hey karo nakamura holding
that position he had no business drawing that game
and we are back with another match in the 2020
speed chess championship alongside me the man
who you can't spell chess without robert hess is
back it's been too long buddy you know honestly
a single day is too long not commentating with
you i missed you man no i mean i feel like this
is one of those things where absence makes the
heart grow fonder and all of a sudden we realize
how much we enjoy working together it's been too
many man no i'm kidding i love how we play the uh
you know the awkward tension role but seriously
we're gonna have a great day today you and i get
to cover a match that we know is a literal coin
flip i think i i mean everybody might might have
their favorite and and could argue different
reasons but don napomnishi versus lavonna brony
and one of the ones you and i had circled and uh
i can't wait to see what we have in store today
yeah absolutely it's one of those matches where
if you hear it's the final round of the candidates
playing for a chance for the world title you
wouldn't be surprised but these two are going
head-to-head they're clashing online and both are
worthy competitors i mean we've seen these players
year after year in the speedchest championship and
i feel like jan de palmashi he's hungry these days
but levon aronian always the steady hand when it
comes to chess so i do think this is a toss-up
these two guys met up a couple years ago we
remember a match that came down to the wire
so we'll see if that happens yet again let's
remind everybody of what the format is and
what that would look like if we came down to the
wire as we always do at the stop sorry at the top
of the of the show at the stop of the show the
stop of the show would be we we drop the mics
and walk out no at the top of the show remind you
of the format it's a single elimination knockout
the 2020 speeches championship is the same
format we've been doing here for a few years
90 minutes of five minutes 16 minutes of three
and 30 minutes of one minute with the one second
increment the great equalizer as we call it
throughout if a match is tied we will have a
four game mini match of bullet we have had one
match go to overtime this year if you missed
the alireza ferrugia versus vladimir putin save
match that is a worthy back back your thing up
and go check out that match was one of one of the
most exciting thrilling things we've had in a long
time uh so but the players are also playing for
a lot robert we've doubled the prizes this year
and uh every game as you know is still worth money
regardless of what the final match score is and
it could be should be fun to see a couple of guys
here who they've been playing this thing since it
was the measly thirty thousand dollars we started
with back in 2016 me and you buddy now they get
a hundred thousand dollars it is amazing to see
the first round match-ups have more prize money
than the whole thing from back in the day and i
honestly have forgotten that it is only round one
because how much excitement there has been the
fedocea ferrugia match that was one of the most
exciting matches of all time no matter the format
no matter who was playing that was excellent
and lavon and jan in the first round this is just
as exciting as it gets absolutely and uh we want
to remind everybody it's also super exciting play
guess the move we have cash prizes being given out
every single time we have a speed chess
championship match and uh you you can throw
your hat in the ring if you're a premium member
you are automatically eligible for cash prizes
just for doing something that's good for your
chess and if you're not a premium member we're
giving away premium memberships pretty much like
participation trophies you um we're like the oprah
of premium memberships you get a premium you
get a premium as long as you're playing guess
the move so uh robert as we look at the bracket
here you and i are about to dive into what we know
is going to be a thrilling match um you've uh you
covered the maxine bache of the grav victory over
niihau sauron with me all the way back on november
1st when we kick things off you've been watching
the last few matches uh what are your thoughts so
far on what you've seen and um you know maybe not
a bold prediction but um maybe you can predict who
mvl would rather face really in terms of the chess
um of yon napomnishi and levon aronian right
because mbl and levon are very close friends
he said as much that he's always rooting for
levon but he knows that a match-up against yon
nepamshi is what many people would love to see
because those two are at atop the leaderboard in
the postponed candidates tournament right after
seven rounds those two players find themselves
in first place so i do think just building up
that tense potential rivalry will be excellent
but as our smarter chess predictions have shown
this is a toss-up a slight nod to yonda pomneshi
based on really the quicker time patrols but danny
you know how i feel about smart chess predictions
what do you think i know how you feel and i
know how we both feel when somehow no matter
how a match starts out it almost always ends
up being more accurate than we would like to
admit at the end although the uh the ferugia
fedo say of match not so not so much um and uh
well regardless yeah i mean i tend to look at that
and do do kind of agree right i guess if we're
we're looking at yon napomnishi's pedigree here
you highlighted that he is currently leading the
candidates at the break with uh who would be his
opponent in the quarterfinals maxine bashilagrov
um but he's also just i think he's just more well
known in the online chess community he's also a
streamer for those who uh who don't know you can
go to twitch.tv slash luscious sq the name you
see right there it's the same as this just.com
username obviously he's not streaming today as
that is strictly forbidden there's this is there
is no banter blitz here this is fully focused
chess players and so we do not allow the players
to stream when they're in the sec but um but go
give them a follow anyway and i don't know if i
if i look at it i just i think that maybe it's
what have you done for me lately robert and that
of course i think of jan is a better bullet player
because he plays more so maybe that'll maybe
that'll catch up with us but i do see him as
maybe the slight nod in the fastest portion and
probably why i would see him with a slight nod
over levon aronian as we take a look now at the
armenia number one and levon's bullet rating is
actually only three rating points lower than uh
yawns which is surprising to me but i think part
of this is that lavon is not a frequent player
in online chess right jan is playing all the time
hikaru farouza fedocev and via all these guys
are regularly online perhaps spent too much of
their time online but lavon he's one of those
players who shies away from the online formats
for the most part unless he's playing on anonymous
accounts so or anonymously playing bug house but
go ahead yeah see he seems like you know more than
i do but danny what i was going to say is that the
extra time the increment should be very useful
to a player like lavon who may not have the mouse
speed as some of the others yep no 100 obviously
we'll talk about that as it goes and it's
something we we always have to draw our attention
to because it i always say keeps the x's and o's
on the board just as much just as important
regardless of how fast the time control gets
um and uh all right well we're gonna be diving
in here we'll see the players on camera in just
a second but let's remind everybody that after
this tomorrow you and i will have the call
when the number one player in the event makes
his debut hikaru nakamura the overall top seed
defending champion and number one as far as
fide blitz goes he'll be playing against hike
marty rosian so this is the first time in our
schedule here of the round of 16 when we've had
back-to-back days so make sure you make note of
that sometimes you watch an scc and you figure
you've got a few days to rest no no not this
week we have got a lot going on so make sure you
already mark your calendar and join us tomorrow
and okay as we uh bring up the players now we uh
we we did have yawn just a second ago we
still have lavon um and uh we're about t minus
60 seconds a little more than that 75 seconds
away from the first game getting started so
last thoughts robert before we are taken
away into the world of scc entertainment
i hope john's getting paid from whatever company
that shares from that's my first thought like he
leaves as soon as we cut to him and that's a
pretty nice looking chair but if you want my
honest chest related thoughts i really think
it depends which yonder palmistry we see today
down at his best can go toe-to-toe with even
magnus carlsen when he's tilting a bit and he
certainly is one of the players who could suffer
from that he can lose four games in a row and
against levon aronian the armenian maestro that's
a dangerous place to be no you're right and that's
something we didn't highlight in all the previews
we went through the smarter chess prediction these
guys have played before but you're right i guess
of the two players if you had to pick somebody
who might be more likely to go on tilt right we
see it happen right hikaru nakamura was active
in the chat when wesley so played his match
just a few days ago and even wesley had some
moments there where we were like okay is wesley
going until right and you were wondering and so
if you had to pick one of these players who might
need to get a control control over their emotions
it probably would be yawn right just because
of his personality and and we've seen him you
know maybe struggle in those in those moments some
moments like that in the past so all right well um
we are we are going to have liftoff here
any second it is exactly time to begin 9 a.m
on the pacific west coast and uh here we go the
games have begun we're going to have some fun
well we're starting with b3 danny so what do
you think of jan's opening choice is he just
you know getting his feet wet or is he just saying
to lavon we're not having standard opening prep
today this isn't going to be a theoretical
i don't know it'll be interesting because
you and i asked that question mbl if you play
yawn in the next round is this a preview in
terms of you know are you going all in right prep
prep uh to be showed maybe this is a preview of
what yawn strategy would be which is no i'm
not i'm not gonna mess with anything that i
might be using in the candidates coming up i'm
gonna be focused on some awkward blitz openings
and it does look really weird because there's a
knight on h3 but that knight will in the future
go to f4 white will push that c2 pawn to c4 and
the bishwan g2 will try to make use of being on
a very nice diagonal if you compare the bishops
the bishop on h7 versus the bishop on g2 you're
trying to pry open those diagonals to make your
bishops better pieces but it seems easier for
white to do so ooh this is another way to kind of
justify the knight being on h3 everybody is you
play for e4 because this pawn chain is conducive
to a pawn storm and now the knight on h3 normally
on a square like f3 is not in the way of the
f-pawn rushing up the board so interesting um
lavonne is going into his first mini think of the
day if this is a sign of things to come you and
i are not going to have a lot to offer in terms
of opening theory today robert it's going to be
buckled up with everybody else let's just you know
let's see what kind of instructive things we can
learn about you know unorthodox positions um and
here comes that knight to f4 right because the d5
pawn now is a target watch out for a timely bishop
takes f6 not now because once you take on f6 and
black takes back the rook on a1 is under attack
but you're trying to remove one of the defenders
of that d5 pawn i think he might be
onto something though i mean they're
you know well lavonne is the guy who normally
loves himself a good old-fashioned exchange sack
so maybe maybe jan doesn't go for that but
again let's bring up the analysis board and
just show very quickly the basic tactics robert
was talking about takes takes you are not quite
jake and baking without losing the rook here
but this is on the agenda now to think about
and see what white wants to do to undermine this
this is an interesting position this bishop on h7
feels odd robert it's like you know hitting a wall
but it also could end up being a sneaky sort of
ninja regaining you know rejoining the fight later
on if anything about this pawn structure changes
yet actually you just made a good point it made me
realize that that bishop will just come back to f5
the vision doesn't have to stay on
h7 anymore because white has already
removed that pawn from e4 so by releasing the
tension you did create a problem that black just
saw by pushing the pawn to d4 but you've also
given more access to that light square bishop
look at this knight come to f1 and after d4 come
right back because of the newly opened squares
given that the pawn advance this is good good
old-fashioned family fun here the high level
shuffling of these two heavyweights uh good
positional stuff just to recognize you don't have
to marry yourself to a plan right you committed
knight f1 to go to e3 to try to undermine the pawn
and then go right back as soon as the squares
are made available i like that by jan although
let's see the computer's starting to like
black position here i wonder is it because
the e file will be opened up and belonged to
black or and i'm guessing is the bishop on b2
danny right that's a bad piece yeah it makes
sense uh but you know it's funny because when
you said that and sorry to interject here but
we said why is black better we often have this
exact same thought process like well we're not
really sure who's better here and the players
they're looking at this position in lavon is
thinking well do i bring that bishop to f5 now
you don't really think am i much better am i you
don't think in terms of computer evaluation but
i do get the sense that uh lavon must be enjoying
his position more now that it's clarified so yeah
yeah it's weird because if yeah if you just look
at the structure here you have to like you have
to like black a little bit because the bishop on
bt as you said is not the most active piece and
a way you might think of undermining and
opening things up might actually give you know
more purpose to to black's pieces so lavon is on
the think and he's down a minute on the clock so
um that's that's a small nod i guess
in uh upon she's direction but uh
not a huge i get this is not like someone taking
time robert because they don't know what they're
doing this is lavon calculating i think i was just
gonna say to commit to a plan and maybe g5 was on
the agenda because i was spying how many squares
does that knight have not many not many good ones
yeah but you know what it does make
your c2 c3 idea more powerful in the
future um because with this pawn now on g5
if that diagonal can really open up black's
king and be in some danger but i like the
current state of affairs and i think kicking
that knight back to e2 then black can swing
that rook to e8 try to take over the e-file
white has less space for his pieces so keeping
more peace on the board is beneficial uh for lavon
yeah it's uh pretty interesting yawn now on the
thing is deciding i mean to me knight e2 seems
like the no-brainer because going to h3 feels
awkward but maybe he thinks going to h3 has
outside chances of not necessarily a sacrifice but
even other moves to try to open up the king like
you're talking about right i mean if the knight
is on h3 and you do eventually open up this bishop
okay no he just no i was just trying to think
what is he thinking about could be 92 seem like
a no-brainer but he does eventually play it yeah
because 93 actually was a required piece sacrifice
from the looks of it right your knight gets
trapped on h3 so you're like yeah right right so
your idea with the sacrifice in g5 is very
interesting but i guess yan he's like let me
let me be calm for game one i doubt he likes his
position um you know he's just chilling there with
uh uh his hand on his chin here but i don't really
like white's position i don't see the future in
it and it just seems easier to play for lavon at
this point agreed and now notice that black is no
longer down on the clock just tuning in uh yawn
at some point was up by a minute but no not not
anymore um you know if we had to rank the time
controls here between these two guys who we know
very well probably you know the reason we agreed
with this mortar just that slightly is that if we
reach bullet john does seem to have the you know
maybe the slight nod so lavonne i think i think
would want to have a game a game or two in his
favor as far as the five minute or three minute
goes okay it's very close to a toss-up in fact by
the way you said it was close is this the closest
to smarter chess stats that predicted any match in
the first round 56 and 40. i think it is i can't
recall a match that was closer but i also don't
listen to smart chess's predictions hard right
you dream about them all the time thinking about
it all the time those are called nightmares danny
you know what it's like to have your kid wake
up screaming that's what it's like for me well
i saw cm back to the beginning highlighting on in
the chess tv chat that the knight on c4 was also
running out of squares but not not really true
because e5 i think was pretty much always on the
agenda and now that this has changed i'm starting
to get a little more nervous for black's position
because i just feel like if c3 comes it might
be worth whatever weakness the d3 pawn becomes
to open up things here and actually black's going
to play b4 next move i have a feeling because of
your idea with c3 and that way i can shut down the
queen side but that also removes most of black's
winning chances so i i feel like if the queen
drops back because it just did black can play
there it is b4 and good luck getting your pieces
open if you're watching yeah that's that's painful
that's yeah awkward but but you know danny
what does black do right like if you give
black three or four free reasonable
moves not hey let me go win a piece
what does black do to crack white structure
it's very solid yeah it's a good point
in an instructive question in general by mr hess
for those who don't know because one of the common
ways you should think about approaching a position
is if you had three or four moves what would what
would you be doing to improve your pieces um not
exactly clear because the drawback even though it
seems very very far-fetched robert is if somehow
this bishop gets anywhere on the board right that
could undermine these these weaknesses on the
dark squares um they could be it could be more
of a more harm than good right and i i agree with
you and you know that's the real pond weakness is
when you look across white structure where are you
going to attack the a2 pawn that's very far away
from the rest of the board and i don't think your
queen can go venture over there in a timely manner
so i do think that the position should peter out
this should be a split point but stranger things
have happened in a time scramble and we're
getting to one minute left for each player
it'll be the first preview we'll have into bullet
as far as what happens in this in this game here
because i don't think we're going to have a lot
of clarity until real time pressure ensues so
here we go king f1 nice little
subtle right little shuffle puck
i'm looking at bishop f5 because i'm
trying to force white's hand do you play
g4 or did you bring your knight back to g1 oh
he put a4 himself so you cannot take on passant
what you can legally take ambassador i would not
advise it because then your a5 pawn will fall and
then your queen side is collapsing so why did
you try to close up the structure over there
and super close not a lot to it yawn is up 30
seconds on the clock but i don't know that it's
going to matter too much we might just have a
both sides feel each other out they uh just call
it peace in the first round here huh and lavon
down to 27 seconds he has half the remaining time
that jan does and we are going to see is this
going to be the lavon from the bullet chess
championships where he uh made the semi-finals if
i'm not mistaken and will he be able to keep peace
and his position looks fine he's great position
that's totally cool but nothing really to do
of note funny i forgot about that and remember he
made it to the semi-finals and was also playing on
horrible internet wherever he was i think he was
on some leg of the grand chess tour and the lobby
wi-fi was just not having it he ended up losing
several games purely because of disconnection and
it was awesome because we had sightings of i think
michael adams made an appearance in the background
yeah yeah yeah who's walking by like what is
aronian doing here playing bullet in the lobby
okay so danny that's what you talked about
those queenside pawns can white's king
run into the game i don't think so but
that's the ideas kd3 king e4 king d5 just
jet that king into the action no and even though
when i highlighted it many moves ago it was kind
of just far-fetched or sort of instructional in
nature but you have to think about advanced pawns
in the middle game everybody are a space advantage
and they're crippling the backward pawns but in an
end game advanced pawns if you haven't exposed
or used them in some way are often targets and
it does seem far-fetched i don't see a clear way
in but if you could if you could get this king
or this bishop in any sort of aggressive spot
black definitely has more weaknesses than white
and four seconds though for lavon he needs
to keep pace because if you say play bishop
e8 here the threat bishop takes f7 and then the
g5 pawn so okay he made a big decision with f4
and is it a good one because now i guess you can't
take on f7 there would have been the inter meso of
taking on g3 with check and now the position is
so close that hey this looks yeah they agree okay
and they just agreed to a draw that final closure
of the position let's bring up the analysis board
just to show exactly how clear that was right
you're literally talking about a deadlock here
no way in for anybody and this knight can sit
on e5 and did it literally laugh in the face of
danger put the king on h8 for fun just to prove
a point i think you could that's how close the
position is that does seem like the type of thing
you would do just i would do that i would i would
actually have already flagged in the game though
so it you know even with the increment um but
all right look at this now this is going to be my
kind of match sorry let's bring back the analysis
board to show the opening while i was focused
on the end game we have a night or ladies and
gentlemen and we have theory here so with lavon
taking the white pieces he goes anti-yondapan
machine plays mainline stuff with queen e2 not as
popular as the traditional queen to d2 but knight
to c6 to be fair was also already a slightly
unique move order uh and uh this is going to be
a theoretical battle here with with white now
um see i don't know i don't know the theory here
before it came to b1 just to show something very
quickly it takes two seconds right you say that
again before king to b1 was played right it looks
like c4 should win a piece because the knight is
pinned on d5 to the queen but the queen goes
to c7 go to the c file pin the c pawn getting
out of the pin and you've created more problems
for yourself than it's worth by pushing a pawn
from your king okay well this will be interesting
again we've been talking a lot about opening prep
everybody because of of dawn uh if he gets by this
he's playing mbl and you know they are leading
the candidates and just what are what cards are
these guys showing in these online events these
days knowing that if and when over the board
chess ever resumes we'll have a candidates and
maybe eventually a candidate to take on magnus
carlson in the world championship so but there's
a lot of money in online events these days so
these guys aren't holding many punches back
it's true and for lavon he's typically we
know him as a d4 player we know that he can
play with both hands expression chess when you
can play with e4 or d4 on the first move right
um so he makes his choice so far in this matchup
by playing e4 in the longer time control so
speaking of holding your prep lavonna roni had a
great norway chest the recently concluded event
that happened he had a very strong performance
gained a bunch of ratings so maybe he is also
trying to keep his openings to himself to continue
his path back towards the top two rating spots
yeah i like that i haven't heard that
expression while he who plays with both hands
that sounds like my nickname from a past life
he who plays with both hands um but okay um
we've got uh yeah no but you're right though
normally when i think of lavon i do think of
a d4 player mostly so if this becomes a theme
today even if it is theory maybe maybe you're
right it's it's theory that's avoiding prep still
um we've got about six thousand of you on twitch
four thousand of you on youtube the matches early
so thanks for being here remember you can go play
guess the move i saw someone on chess tv just
asking that a second ago there's a button right
below the chest tv player you can click and you'll
be taken to live chess and uh instantly following
every game as it starts so go play guess the
move to win cash prizes and if you're looking
for the button our mods can maybe help share
a link on twitch and youtube and on chess tv
all you got to do is just click right below the
player in front of you the real question i have
danny is dragon b70 winning guess the move again
is that's what happened today he's he's won he's
won i think three of the four matches so far wait
do you know who was playing indian lad we have
gm's joining to guess the move oh i love it i can
type and by the way if you want to see you do you
do a command slash guessing you just do a command
slash guessing and you can see everyone who's
currently playing guess the move and yeah indian
lad is playing dragon b70 of course title players
um but yeah there you go um all right back to this
position john got the better of it it seems and
just looking regardless of what the computer says
everybody just objectively normally black if black
is getting pressure before white has done anything
with the english attack pawn storm no real
uh side effects of having the king in the
center you have to like black and these kind
of night orbs i always say if you start moving
pawns around your king position in a race game
it's usually a bad sign um and look at this king
f7 the king is that's how good it's getting from
black your king is not going to castle but
it's perfectly safe here the queen on a4 is
running out of squares sneakily that queen could
get trapped over there and also look at the c3
square if black had a free move queen takes c3
is what i'm looking at with a knight fork at the
end of it let's show that to the analysis board we
shout we shall go queen takes c3 oh man delicioso
dora even the computer likes you robert see you
don't always have to hate computers in your life
look at that queen take c3 is on the agenda for
black but you also highlight if i make another
random move on the analysis board that the queen's
kind of getting trapped and i think queen takes
c3 is just winning but even b5 and b4 is coming
forget the a pawn i don't even need it right if i
pry open counter play that's all i need in a race
position like this where both sides are looking
for checkmates so yeah this this is not a great
game two for lavon aronian right now and queen
takes either is possible right now would not be
surprised if john goes ahead and steals that pawn
it's free there's i bet there's some sort of trick
now the bishop guards c2 i just have a feeling
knowing the coffeehouse trickster
that levon ironian has been called
i have i'm just gonna play queen
dick c3 to see what the computer says
okay maybe it is okay i i'm gonna go
back now that's like flirting with danger
look but don't touch look but don't touch the
but it looks like it actually did work for black
so he's just playing the smart you
know coordinating move of rook to
d and maybe this queen is going to
get trapped on a5 like maybe that's
really his plan is to eventually play b6
they forget the apon right i mean it's got
to be just a crushing attack here you've got
everybody where it's supposed to be over here
and g4 okay so this is what you need but okay
b6 the queen has one square after b6 queen takes
a6 only move and there must be a way to trap
that queen right danny there has to be a way
um ah yeah there is yeah c7 knight c7 after
that oh nice c7 is that it so b6 26 knight
c7 because the queen is losing let's go to
the analysis board and show it because i
still don't know why he's not playing
it but if it's b6 takes and knight c7
the queen would have to go to a7 just winning the
queen he just he just missed that i think that's
pretty straightforward b6 queen takes a6 only
move knight c7 again everybody every square is
guarded right now by a black piece the queen has
no squares between a7 and rook a8 robert was right
i mean john is taking his time here but he's
now gone away and the evaluation has swung
wildly back i mean we were looking at
a position that if yon had found b6
it was plus seven for black the queen was bye-bye
yeah it's uh in some ways you know we're here we
see the eval bar saying it's hugely in black's
favor you're like okay let me go find an idea
that could win the game let's go trap the queen so
it is much easier in this case to find it but for
jan he has to find that he's so strong he's one
of the best handful of players on this planet he's
more than capable of finding that but his position
still remains excellent but especially because he
has a little bit of time here i mean he's still
he's still up about two minutes on the clock but
when you're when you have more time i mean you
just feel like you should slow down there and
figure out the way to convert on that but all
right everybody is primed for liftoff right
like at saga i need to pounce
love right i could say come on
you're all right you are right danny
exotic over there like everything happens
and it's soggy and wild looking as you
crouch up on his man bun like a tiger
all right v6 a while ago ready to pounce um
by the way if queen takes a6 is knight b4 will
move now because queen takes c2 what i think it
is yeah i think it is let's see if he finds it
knight before the queen can
retreat and all you're all you're
actually winning is the bishop here unless
there's something on a2 now that would be wild
no i think you're right it's over the bishop pair
so john's position still looks very good because
the bishops are strong in a position like this
with action happening on both sides of the board
and at the end of some of these lines maybe
black can just gobble up the f3 pawn because
if that pawn is removed look out for e5
and f5 becoming queens later in this game
right so he takes it there's got to be something
on the light squares here like i mean i think
that's what he's going for he's just like look
there's no way white's surviving this queen a4
um you can throw in a tempo but i actually don't
want to chase the queen to this side of the board
everybody you don't want to yeah so queen a4 makes
a lot of sense now just something where is it
okay it says seven rook takes c3 check
right like it just take on c3 take on a2
dude that's it let's do it to the analysis board
if you just found that rook takes c3 the computer
believes it you're right it's made in six well
i saw the eval bar it says maiden seven so i
trust me i wasn't just being like oh i
could see mate and seven off the top of
my head no problems but i mean this move
at the end look how freaking dirty that is
oh we found it rook takes c3 and
we're gonna have a good day everybody
that's how you that's how you have liftoff
wait wait wait danny um it said mate in four
i think if that's i can see that yeah so
young clearly always you know what it was
that was sick oh my god if you're playing guess
the move and you found queen takes a2 and yawn
didn't if you can prove it to me with a screenshot
you get a diamond membership okay because that's
the move you should have guessed and yawn
didn't see it by the way he better convert this
okay to the analysis board we got to show it
levon's shaking his head he's not happy about you
guys on king b1 queen takes a2 and then bishop
takes and if the king goes back you just give
check and rook a8 someone just said in chat that
needs to be in puzzle rush uh platinum member fire
fangled if you send me a message with this game
please i'll remember to submit these uh these
tactics to puzzle rush seriously send me send
me a message with these games because i forget
hell i don't remember my name half the time so
uh i forget a lot of things so send me a message
uh fire laying lead bang lead and um all right
let's bring back the the end of that game real
quick just to show it we got a little
distracted with the hype but that was
still still a fanciful finish robert not quite the
queen sack for mate but yawn does get the job done
and it's time for lavon to rethink his uh his
english attack i guess yeah i wonder if levon
will switch to d4 or c4 playing english that is
his standard style and well john sticks to his b3
and these kind of openings right white is playing
with pieces and black is getting more control over
the center with pawns than is typically the case
and danny i know you're going to crack a joke so
i'll crack it first does it not remind you of the
bad closest science i played since i was a kid
i don't even have to because uh me
and don you just had some fun together
talking about about your opening so i i already
got out of my system for the day um but yeah no
although jokes aside you know now that d4 has been
played he righted the wrong of the close sicilian
and uh has has sort of transitioned into what
is what is this now this is a double fianchetto
hedgehog sicilian dragon i mean what is this
you're asking the wrong person if you want to
know the names of openings that was a long address
double fee and kettle hedgehog sicilian dragon
and look at this bishop g4 was played
and he drops the knight back to e2
because typically you don't want to push
upon to f3 as that makes the dark squares
much more loose and can be problematic for your
king but dropping the knight back to e2 feels very
passive and look what levon just did he brings
queen to c8 guess what here comes the eventual
bishop of h3 try to trade off your nice fiance
bishop apparently grandmaster indian lad does
legit want that cash prize he's not giving up on
guess the move so there you go um right now what
not even in first place right now so if you've
ever wanted to beat a grandmaster guess the move
is probably your easiest path to success we'll
go to the analysis board real quick to show the
opening that robert was talking about and again
jokes about the close sicilian aside that's not
the the main thing that black has advantages in
this structure is that you have control over the
center while maintaining flexibility this pawn
can move one twice you could actually go for e6
and d5 so you know one of the reasons why white
doesn't play like uh doesn't play things like d3
and and go for another plane and give black that
flexibility is because because of that because of
all the options black has so white transitions
to an open center but this is a weird way to do
it and i'm with robert that the tempe black has
gained now bishop h3 this already just looks like
like white has gotten like a bad version of a
meroxie bind right all the weak dark squares and
and black is kind of ahead of an initiative
here straight strange opening choice by john
who's clearly going out of his way as
white today to avoid mainline theory
yeah that's certainly the case and typically in
these moroxy bind structures i mean this knight
doesn't really want to be on d2 it's limiting
the scope of any major pieces that come down to d
file and black is very solid no matter the muroxy
bind position it's often that black is cramped but
very solid and if you look at the pawn structure
white's pawn structure is actually looser think
about pawn breaks how can white create a pawn
break not so easy to accomplish without creating
more vulnerable squares but on for black a6
to b5 for instance e6 and d5 comes to mind
so it just seems easier for black to control
the kind of imminent dynamic of the position and
this will be one of those destructive moments we
rarely get as human brand masters will say or or
i'm not but we'll pretend that i'm playing one
on tv today that rob and i would disagree with
the general way an engine evaluates it because
the algorithms are taught to evaluate things
mathematically like space there's an objective
viewpoint of white has a little bit more space but
this is one of those positions where the longer
the game goes and when black does eventually
manufacture some sort of breakthrough white is
going to have more potential weaknesses here
and the the objective math giving white an edge
because of space i would actually disagree with i
think the black is like it's in a very comfortable
position here you could even consider moving the
knight and offering a trait of dark sport
bishops just to dominate the dark squares
like if you imagine black getting a piece on one
of these beautiful outpost squares somehow so
anyway i like lavon's position we liked him in
the first game as black robert we'll see if he
can do a little better this time you know what i
don't like though this is clock management because
right now john it's up a minute and a half and
it's not an easy position to play despite the
fact that we both like black's position we think
it's sturdy it's not easy to actually progress
do you play b5 now or is that too risky opening
the c5 do i try to play for d5 or is that not
realistic so i do think some of these decisions
are more difficult than i initially made it seem
but i still like levon's position even if i
think he is struggling about that clock you
said it well the only thing we don't like is is
the clock management right and um you see john
had to play f3 because he was worried about the
queen and knight doing double duty over here um
so we'll see if if levon can
speed up a little bit knight d3
a little awkward yep he's trying to clearly
trying to bring his pieces towards that queen
side and and i think he was kind of threading
c5 i guess or definitely a possibility
and now c5 is is possible if he wants to i guess
there is some downside of a knight d4 shot at some
moment because then the rook on c8 attacks c5 as
well so you have to be careful before pushing that
pawn but it's something to consider definitely
now he put queen e3 so maybe it is what's next
well we see the position slowly kind of creep into
to be very comfy for black like has a teeny bit
of an edge in these positions and likely either
c4 will become a target an isolated pawn of some
kind or you'll or you'll blink first but usually
taking is bringing more activity to black's pieces
the one long-term thing you always have to
think about in these dragon sicilian kind of
meroxybund structures is watch out for a quick
simplification and then suddenly at the end of
a line where the smoke cleared white actually has
a two on one on the queen side now black always
gets the breakthrough of d5 in exchange for that
anytime there's a trade here but you got to watch
out a little bit for end game transitions when
you're black and somehow a quick outside pass pawn
i think that's an incredibly instructive point
in what we might see because i would probably do
exactly that take on a7 take on b5 and maybe play
f4 because if the queen's off the board your king
is not going to feel unsafe when you start pushing
your pawns but he doesn't go for that he goes for
knight f1 instead and what if you take on c4 now
you're giving yeah yeah i was going to say i don't
like john's decision oh yes yeah that was his idea
then because you and i were both thinking why did
yon do that to give himself an isolated pawn but
he has some clear really has some tricky idea
that's a really nice idea by jan because he's
creating complications out of a position that
seemed quite tame he is still up a minute on
the clock and now that two on one majority
that becomes very difficult to hold in an end
game if you're thinking from lavon's perspective
because most of the action is focused in the
center i can use the queenside pawns as a decoy
yeah and he also he forced this
move knight d3 right i mean because
knight d6 would have lost the d6 pawn
everybody so that's that was a key thing
that robert was saying is that now he forces
that two-on-one end game where white has um
but you know as long as the queens are on the
board robert look at that move queen b7 lavon
just said you missed your chance buddy guess what
i'm going to do i'm playing for d5 and i'm going
to open up these light squares i like it you
can also play for e5 as black and throw your
knight into d4 so then f1 is clearly misplaced
and now d5 looks good i mean now the knight is
getting into the game let's bring up the analysis
board because i actually think john's idea was
really interesting but he should have combined
it with mine and robert's approach which was
take on a7 at some point maybe first and and
head to the end game where he has the two on
one and some sort of end game like this knight
end games are close to king and pawn endings this
would have been different than what we now have
levon did not have to be asked twice to keep the
queens on the board with the transition of the
c pawns which makes d5 uh a real option so i'm
i'm getting a feeling that lavon might strike
back here and level the score in this match
the position is starting to look very good for
him time is becoming about even and that's always
not always i shouldn't say that but often a good
indicator right danny when one player is well
ahead in the clock the position starts getting
a little murkier and they're also using that
time advantage and it goes away completely so i do
think that lavon as we see his face on screen too
he is deeply concentrated and probably quite
concerned because after e takes d5 black doesn't
have to recapture that pawn will be pinned on
the diagonal so block could actually play move
like knight to e7 or even stronger by knight to
b4 hitting the rook and then going knight takes
d5 with all sorts of discoveries yeah no let's
show that real quick i mean that's the main point
we've been highlighting is that the opening of
the position oops the opening of the position
can only favor black with a king here and a bunch
of pawns that have wandered away too far so so
john doesn't do that he plays knight f3 oh but
does 95 in the end 95 oh we missed it 95 is coming
there it is 95 is coming oh and and jan
just he said something that probably isn't
appropriate for our audience here i
don't know he didn't seem very happy
yeah he's whispering for the kids watching
he's whispering just you know sweet nothings um
and the point everybody is that the rook on c1 is
not defended and the queen is also under attack
so you would have to combine those pieces maybe
queen move to protect the rook but once the rook
is captured the queen can't capture back without
dropping the knight on f3 which is now attacked
two times that was about as tricky as you can
make it because yawn is going to take with check
um and of course it's still winning for
black but that was a creative little
little move by yon to say i'm i'm lost i
blundered but look it's still going to make
you beat me here up the exchange and lavon takes
a breath he's winning he knows it so he plays f6
oftentimes that can weaken your king here white's
king is actually in worse shape so rook c2
check and that queen can come into d5 and help
you probably land to check me in the near future
here it comes i mean how does white drum okay
g4 so let me ask you how white drums up some
counter play that does seem to be the best chance
but h5 for black just go all in go check me yeah
do it open the king although then maybe queen a7
check i forgot the queen gets slide over there and
oh yeah don't blunder me
let's kill that real quick
if h5 queen a7 check king h6 would be a
problem yeah that would be good oh wait
he did allow the queen it okay but he's
got different ideas walking the king out
also he put us on h6 rather
than h5 so that was interesting
yeah i think okay now there's g5 is for g5
victory march look at the clock by the way
jan is literally living on the increment here
and he's going nope where's the mate there has
to be a checkmate somewhere there has to be
made but john is living on the increment here
okay we're going to have a time scramble here
we're going to have a photo finish yawn there
could be some kind of perpetual if you're not
careful like quinn h yeah you could lose now
now lavon is down to two seconds oh my gosh and
look how well placed the queen on c3 is though
guarding f6 just perfect that's huge now rook f2
queen d6 no checks for you now we're waiting for
rook f2 there you go now he's got it i think
queen c6 no the checks are gonna happen oh no
more checks that's really well done technique but
where's the knockout three oh nice nice finish
oh that was nasty oh man we'll bring
up the analysis board it's mate rook f3
found with seconds on the clock
the point is knight takes f3
queen takes f3 oh wait no no wait wait it wasn't
mate no it's not me it was just it was a trick
well you probably win these king and pawning games
as my guess but that was uh that's a good point
that's a good point you can take either
way and win the kingdom upon ending okay
all right so lavon wasn't just tricking his way to
that particular time scramble victory he was also
converting oh yeah but that is good to see
if you are a levon aronian fan that in these
time scrambles he clearly has what it takes to
convert great positions and to find these uh
simplifications that are not easy to spot
at first glance yeah and at the same time
you got to give credit to yon because he was he
blundered right straight up but what did he do
right he gathered himself and said all right well
the best chance i have is x right to go to this
queen and knight thing and he almost got himself
you know a draw there right and i think that um
that's a that's a good thing to see just as far
as like you know when you know you're in the right
mental frame of mind robert like talk a little
because what's the psychology of not just when
things are going well but when you screw up right
and the ability to take a breath and then gather
yourself is probably a much more you know less
talked about skill but just as important skill
right yeah and there is a time and place to resign
and that game certainly was not one of those
instances but it is difficult when you're worse to
have the motivation to fight back especially when
you're much worse you blunder a clean exchange
you know that objectively you're lost but to have
that willpower and to sustain that effort it's
difficult to see yan do that in the early going
he knows it's going to be a tough battle these two
competitors have so much respect for one another
and you're right it is good to see if you're a fan
of yana pannashi when you see him fighting until
the very last second and he honestly had chances
until the very end yeah he almost swindled himself
a draw there and shout out to our uh our sub there
cat rocket move because that's a 12 month sub
we appreciate a full year of support there um
5 000 of you on youtube 8 000 on twitch and
thanks for being here look at levon's position to
start this one this is uh he goes he goes back to
e4 so he's gonna stick to that even though
we think of lavon sometimes as a d4 player
but this is a lot better than that than that
bogus english attack he had in game two he's
clearly better in this position and black has
some trouble on the a file yeah black eyes trouble
on the a file also white can consider pushing
that pawn to b5 and maybe even to b6 and then
he does it immediately right it's like don't
even bother thinking about the position because
white has a protected pawn by a bishop and the
pawn a5 there's already one piece attacking it
but watch out in the future if multiple pieces
go and the knight gets into b3 hits that a5 pawn
maybe then i can even come to b3 to d4 trying
to get to these vulnerable e6 and c6 squares
this does not look very good i agree f5 is
a move that well from an aggressive point
of view makes sense you're trying to undermine the
protection of the pawn here and unleash the bishop
but it also is clearly clearly a move
of some level of desperation because
super weakening to black's light squares
i like your idea it probably is a little
too slow for this exact position because
black can take and then take here twice
but there's got to be some of the move here okay
so he takes first and you know what jenny is funny
the e7 pawn is a backward pawn like not only
are the squares weak at the end of this if you
let's say some pieces clear out in the e file or
rook comes to e1 we're going to be just putting
pressure on e7 into the end of the game so that's
what lavon is transitioning to here yeah even
even the e3 square i mean there's there's this
potential that white is in a position to really
go gangbusting over here on this uh this e file
here i mean this is gonna be a problem the e pawn
and black really needs to keep this knight on e5
because if white's bishop gets to d4 and you trade
off that fiance bishop that rook on a3 is going
to land on g3 and go checkmate that black king
right so you have to be careful in all directions
at this point trading there was almost necessary
for black because of the threat you already
highlighted some route that pony was headed to the
e6 square so black had to get it off um but yeah
this is a position where white holds all the cards
i think patience patience would be a virtue here
i mean what could you do you could just play queen
d3 guard the pawn and build up e file plans rookie
one bishop g5 you could even play bishop d4 right
away here try to do your idea in fact he does it
um i kind of like that i know it sacks the b-pawn
but that's more my style you know it's just a
good decision frankly i mean the king is not
going to survive without defending yeah so if you
go queen takes beef oh my god he does it because
you can combine all these ideas bishop g7 king
takes g7 then play rook e1 i was gonna say queen
check i mean you can combine them as my point
like if they're rookie one you don't even have
a good way to defend e7 because if you put a
rook on f7 or e8 i bishop h5 coming yeah to kick
your rook off this uh these squares let's just
let's bring up the analysis board there's gonna
be a lot of tactics here to show as lavon tries
to finish this one off i mean taking and just
i was looking at some idea like this
where i could swing but maybe that's
too slow black can stop rook g3 you
were just saying just rookie one here
and the best news danny is you have ideas of queen
a one check as well to win the a5 pawn if that's
moves it's just too much is happening and it's
all bad for black robert's point everybody is
that regardless of how you might try to defend
it bishop h5 is on the agenda and your rook is
not only under the attack but seven pawn is a
problem but there's i wonder if there's something
even better like some like inner inner meso like
rook b3 you force the queen back i don't even know
it's funny danny there's like subtle inter messes
there i feel like those are ones that are easiest
for me to miss personally because i'm sometimes
get this laser focus on the attack and he goes
for this line where he uh trades and puts queen
on a1 with the check but i get so focused on like
how to conclude the game that sometimes that
little move is the best way forward it just
for me it's hard to register yeah i don't even
know if it was i mean it just felt like a really
tricky thing to do and kick the queen back
but lavon obviously calculated something or
we wouldn't be here and he's his next move will
probably be revealing um yeah i think rookie one
is i mean this just oh you know he's he has some
variations he's like bishop e2 i was just gonna
say that that you move the bishop with tempo to
get rook g3 so like but i was calculating it oh
no this is even better because you get the rook in
first so now bishop e2 isn't even stacking a piece
wow so yeah because rook g3 oh my gosh and
actually if black plays f4 the bishop goes
back to g4 and into e6 wait what is the
queen he's playing for pawns over there
interesting he gave up on the uh it was obviously
it's hard you know they you know they don't have
the same eval bar telling you that there's blood
in the water and it'll be a shark but he's just
kind of converting on what seems simple he's
wins the pawn still has this bad king to expose
but definitely definitely not the most
direct way to victory some sort of path of
bringing the rook to the king's side was doctor
ordered there his position is still great right
yes much weaker the bishop on b7 is staring into
a wall that's defended and so white's pieces
pretty much across the board are in better shape
but it just feels like there was a knockout there
and i didn't see it concretely but it did feel
like there was one and maybe he's gonna find a
different one but like uh i don't i'm trying
to figure out where does this rook belong
for white do i go rook b3 to swing it back
to g3 to go rook b4 potentially i love this
queen g5 if you could just put the bishop
on e6 it's lights out you can't get there no
but this is a tough move to deal with because
rook f7 and rookie eight are both met by bishop h5
i guess i thought so so bishop h5 there
will be a rook g7 you're just barely
hanging on there yeah you got to be careful
because you don't want to lose the d5 pawn
uh but he's he's smart to bring the h pawn up
right because he can just push that pawn all
the way to h6 and then put bishop h5 that's
what he needs to get the e7 pawn to fall
just keep pushing push it right h5 danny just
keep on going alpha alpha zero put it on h6
that's a good move too but by the way h6 and
bishop back to h5 with the oh wait yeah the
rook was hanging lol wake up going on here but
that would have been the best idea had the rook
not been under attack so i'm with you yeah this
is this is doing work right now and i think that
jan will not repeat this opening this opening it
did not go well for him yeah this particular one
will back up and run through it uh quickly the
cement it in our in our storyline for the day in
case yawn does maybe make the mistake of repeating
it but early on in these matches you see the five
minute portion both sides kind of feeling each
other out um as the time controls get faster less
time to think that sounds like a yogi berra but
as the time controls get faster there's less time
to think yeah i was i was thinking the same thing
full of just incredible wisdom danny all right all
right oh this here comes queen g5 and it's rover
yeah because the bishop what can he just please
on basant is dirty um and queen d4 is a threat
for mate on g7 so but there's rook takes g2 oh
i actually think it's still wait i think it is
still winning it is but i didn't see rook takes
g2 because because it takes yeah he goes for it
takes no i think there's no chat you know it makes
me seem like i saw this all very i didn't even
see rook takes g2 as possible i'm gonna become
that's funny well i was giving you the benefit
of the doubt i was like yeah on poisson is good
but there's rook takes g2 but turns out it
didn't matter you were right just winning
um yeah but he is ten seconds left uh wait he
just missed queen c4 jack oh he's got bishops
whoa oh man hey white is still winning but what
a wild finish this position is here allowing uh
there's some sort of draw with bishops oh my
god bishop d3 you trade on e2 and then you go
queenie six check i think and then you can win
oh my god lavon let it slip whoa what is going
on oh my god he gives him his queen he wins oh god
he can even just take now ea queen and it's over
oh my gosh what a weird game that was
and yawn's playing it out here everybody
just to test lavon's uh you know internet
connection if you will on the increment but
let's bring back the analysis board because
what a weird finish that was lavonne
played a masterful game but actually
blundered a draw here on bishop check but it
looks like black missed queen e6 this was the move
robert and after king d2 what's the i mean this is
a cool and i think i think you can ache e7 maybe
wow oh wait you actually have
queen e5 so you could take the rook
oh wow there's no queen c3 check because you
can block that's important that's essential
that that is yeah with seconds and clockwise
finish there and lavon just uh converts in
in a crazy time scramble and okay well this is
going to be a fun day today i think that we we
said this was going to be a nail-biter if you're
just tuning in the smarter chef's predictions
uh confirmed by the team here closest first-round
matchup we've we've uh predicted anyway right
and predictions are to give robert aneurysms
so that's why they're here right they're
not actually you know the chess but we have
predicted a close match so don't go anywhere
and you know this is one of those moments where i
had mentioned levon he's pretty solid as a player
and jan it seems like he's more emotional and
a lot of the top players will say that he is
incredibly strong capable of winning every term
that he plays but there are moments where he gets
a bit emotional and throws his chances away so
danny he's now down in the score but it is very
early i don't think he's you know too bothered
by the score but what do you make of the start
do you think that we might see a different yawn
come out soon i wonder if if it continues to go
this way if he'll if he'll abandon his unorthodox
openings approach right we know that yawn is one
of the best players in the world and one of
the most well prepared players in the world um
so again if you're if you're just tuning in i'll
just back up quickly and go through the opening
this has been all day e3 by yawn and and this
approach of some sort of not very uh well-traveled
road by white has been what uh the pond richie's
been doing and if he falls behind in the match
does he abandon that approach i think he's gonna
fight he will yeah but i think he will because
what he's been doing has allowed lavonne
a relatively easy escape from the opening
stage and often when you're playing with the
black pieces against a player of yawn's caliber
these super great masters is you want to put
pressure on your phone early sometimes it's subtle
other times it's quite direct but the point is
that black has to make some important decisions
that isn't just oh i'm blundering upon
now it's at the future direction of the
game and here you look at the position black has
several options that look good i would consider
bishop e6 simple development i would consider
queen to e7 i would consider moving my knight
away knight to d7 to open up my bishop on
g7 so i feel like black has quite a bit of
what i was letting you finish i didn't want
to didn't want to take your sandwich there
i first of all i supported every word that was
coming out of your mouth i think a solid approach
was uh but that was a as far as prep goes robert i
know it's hard to say that because there's no way
they played this is not this is not a an or you
know a very well-known opening but the idea of the
b-pawn being able to be pushed there and not be
taken let's go to the analysis board why couldn't
white just take the pawn right what a wild
decision there i know e4 was hanging but
let's do it can you actually take this i guess
so at least that's the claim so you take a nice
central pawn for your pawn closer to the flank so
yeah there's there's no tricks here everybody i
mean among other things i think black can just
develop and defend everything so there's the
lavon who took a lot of time 37 seconds to be
exact uncorks b5 when we were looking for kind
of a solid subtle maneuvering approach and lavon
says no thank you guys i got this let me drive
it's one of the many reasons that you know he is
where he is and i am where i am is that you know
he finds ideas like this just pretty quickly and
b5 is not something that ever came to my mind it's
like an aggressive approach in a solid position
he's like you know i'm not okay with just simple
equality i don't want to make yon feel comfortable
that he's just going to hold the balance i don't
know i'm going to create some immediate
problems for him that was quite beautiful
well black is a little bit better but also has
the d6 pawn to worry about um did interesting
position right because you could you could take
and double the c pawns but that actually increases
white strength in regards to your pawn being weak
so most likely result is just equality here i
mean black can also trade here everybody and then
walk the king to e7 to make sure that this pawn is
not going to be forgotten but we'll see if levon
comes up with yet another creative way to maybe
play for more than equality here but your ultimate
point is a great one that even though white's pawn
structure looks worse with double isolated c
pawns black has the easiest pawn to target on d6
white has more space for the rooks what does
rooks need they need open lines and with two
rooks in the d-file hitting the d6 pawn and blacks
work on d8 staring into its own pawn protecting it
white's pieces are just better and
quite significantly better at that
yeah yeah yeah
so what do you think that lavon is considering
here i'm wondering i mean one idea is
it's a little too slow sometimes you can put a
piece on a square that's protected by a weak pawn
with the idea that if they ever trade you take
and you fix your weakness in this case i think
that that's just too slow because white has
rook d1 and the threat of trading is too much
but i was wondering if there was some
idea where h2 would be anyway i was
considering bishop b5 that was the short answer
i have no idea what yawn is considering now now
bishop e5 is completely not possible because it
would blunder a piece right but you could you
could even trade and play bishop f8 i know that's
horrible i know don't yell at me don't yell at me
it's actually a horrible idea e5
even just wins okay now you can yell
yeah i'm not gonna yell at you because
i actually think it's not as bad as
we both initially thought but look
what he's doing lavon this whole game
hey i said i can be solid i can make this
position as balanced as possible but let
me avoid that but danny here's 42 seconds and gone
is over three minutes that's been the story of the
day i mean john has had more time on the clock
as he does when he plays most opponents but um
but it hasn't deterred lavonne i mean he's
converted obviously he has a one-game lead
um black is saying hey i'm the one playing for two
results here i'm not just going to sit passively
and defend my weak d6 pawn i want more and he's
defending it tactically because somebody asked
like wait wasn't that pawn hanging directly but
black would have thrown in a rook a1 check and
scooped off the first let's show that tactic real
quick because that's an instructive one never
forget if you take pawns x-ray tactics exist you
check and take and the rooks actually defend each
other through the white rook x-ray vision it's
perfect given i saw someone in twitch chat earlier
saying that love yon is like superman and lavon is
like batman with the prep and the kryptonite right
i like that reference i do too but i never watched
that movie because it seemed like it was gonna
be horrible oh yeah no the dc movies when are
they gonna get it right hashtag marvel ftw um
but uh but it is an interesting thing right
i love the i love the uh the reference there
the x-ray vision tactic was also instructive and
now black is also still pushing a little bit it's
it's close to equality but the king is going to be
the more active piece than the white counterpart
and that's a huge advantage in an engine like this
i don't know and now also black's pawn structure
it looks better because white has this
isolated b pawn it looks protected for now
but once those bishops get traded
that pawn on b3 immediately a target
and there goes the bishops you have to take with
the rook and i guess white is solid here because
you can put a second rook on the b5 but the rook
on c3 does stabilize the position and if i were
young i would consider starting to push some
of the king side pawns but no he's worried he
was worried about rook b to a8 and there it goes
yeah i'm gonna say the problem with that plan for
lavon is it looks pretty with the rooks on the b
file but where's the beef right what's the finish
so instead lavon is going for something
a little more aggressive with the rooks
but now he has to trade back because his yawn gets
pressure on d6 so probably this should be a draw
nice move very important move by yon they're
playing e5 because jan had two separate isolated
pawns now he'll trade off one of his isotopes from
black's good pond and it's mutually isolated pawns
and we'll see how this goes mutually isolated
yeah i thought that was like a story of like a
it sounds like a nicholas sparks like love novel
mutually isolated you know enough dear john movies
for white so in certain scenarios if black
is forced to you know trade the b-pawn for
the e-pawn that would require the black king to
start going out to the queen's end okay that's not
happening black is too active and it's just going
to be austin i imagine you're on there yan says
no i'll play for a little more now you've gotten
yourself under some time pressure john probably
could have just checked that one out right pickle
this one home as they say take a draw um okay a no
and it's gonna be a draw but in theory
outside past pawns it should be better
for white if somehow if you could just take here
and the white king takes here the problem is
black's king is more centralized so it's not
going to be that simple yeah we're going to trade
well white's king is closer black's king is
more active and so it's an easy cut off um
always remember outside passport principles
if somehow the starting was black king here
and white king here white would be winning
because of that outside passer but as it was
we have a draw the old-fashioned way and uh
again second draw of the day actually right
indeed that is the case and wait where'd they go
i have no idea where the players are going but it
seems like they work something out that was odd
yeah i i guess they had asked for a okay a mutual
often and that is part of the rules everybody
that this is a grueling format the scc
and let's go ahead and bring it back up
because we have a moment remind you that the
90 minutes of five minutes and the clock ticking
is something that always happens even if you got
to go to the bathroom doesn't matter if your
doorbell rings right the clock doesn't stop
and you're actually not allowed to delay
rematching by more than any sort of you
know reasonable measure you can be penalized but
if the players agree you know someone has to use
the restroom or you know someone has something um
then obviously we have no reason to uh to hold to
that so someone had to go and then guess what you
gotta go and speaking of which if you're on the go
why you gotta go some people gotta go and
they use the phone while they're on the go
i should probably go away from this rabbit
hole that i'm going down but i'm gonna keep
going for it if you're on the go grab the phone
you know what the most popular type of puzzle
brush is toilet puzzle rush back to the chest
robert so how do you expect me to talk about
high-level chess after you have been discussing
bathroom breaks you know there's a reason some
people wear pampers it allows you to pee-pee
without having to go anywhere oh god i'm gonna be
here all week don't forget to tip your waitress i
was waiting for you to make that joke you made it
in a much worse way than i expected i'm not i
feel like a disappointed high school teacher
where i should be giving you detention but i'm
slightly amused so i won't do that right exactly
no it's it's like when my 15 year old makes an
inappropriate joke and like my wife is in the
room and i'm like like i don't want to acknowledge
that it was a good one right it's just not the
right audience right so i get it yeah i also
you know if i give you detention i have to stay
you know late one day not really worth my time but
anyway back to this chest position where we have
what looks like a kero con or like an exchange
karo khan but it was from the sicilian so it's
interesting how different openings can still
lead to yeah let's let's back up real quick
we'll bring up the analysis board how in the
world did we get here because you said it was
a keracon and then i looked at the eco but no
it was a sicilian oh okay duh it was an allopin
but that changes the structure remember open
sicilians occur with d4 allopin idea with c3
it's going to lead to a different kind
of game don't blunder knight takes e4
very common trap everybody you lose your pony out
of the opening i may or may not have fallen for
that a few times some people have to learn things
more than once okay don't judge me but either way
the structure does eventually change and we
get i mean you called it a keracon it could be
a number of different structures now and i i i
do like what black has gotten assuming that he
doesn't lose the e pawn for uh for without some
defile compensation coming like the d3 square
right there's much more hope
than the carrot con right yeah
i'm only four episodes in so don't ruin anything
for me just so you know i've only seen the first
four episodes of the queen's gamut but i gotta
get good job dude everybody in the world has
watched and is talking about the queen's gambit
and the critics love it you hear it was just
it was just raided on rotten tomatoes as the
best show of 2020. okay and what's your point
i mean i personally love the boys season
two if i was doing the rankings i mean i
don't know i know i'm supposed to go with
the chess movie but um i haven't seen the
second season of that either so you know
what i'm a little behind on my shows danny
have you seen the unicorn i feel like you
would really like that show but we just want
to talk about chess so how did we get into a
conversation about because cecaro tweeted that
he thought the queen's gambit was the best
portrayal of chess in entertainment to date
a lot of people feel that way so anyway back
to the chest so we're in an equal position
with nothing but a ball point of jelly or
white and the extra pawn on the queen side
yeah so but b2 is clearly a target there could be
some problems on the e file with a quick rookie a
hitting both minor pieces that are there and why
not queen e2 that's my first instinct is just put
my bishop c5 with tempo instead interesting i
agree explain these things to me danny bishop
five got all kinds of weird tempe to calculate we
do one knight b2 the rook could go to e8 i mean
to the batcave let's do it if queen to
d1 is played and you take with a tempe
i'm just saying i don't know and then i
play rookie a like oh there's knight d6
oh but then i have rookie two what was
the move why was probably winning there
i just i think it looks as complex as you're
making it out to be it really does look like
a position where there are tactics on b2
but i guess bishop f8 is always possible
yeah i guess you just take everything directly
and in the end okay yeah big here take care
okay but all right so lavonne played bishop
c5 he's given yawn some things to calculate
and he's still thinking here so it's now for a
change lavon up on the clock and he's up that pawn
and rookie will be knight
well once we established the knight
b2 was not an option i mean rookie was
kind of the only move so jan eventually
plays it i think we'll see a trade on d6
and white's gonna be up a pawn in the end game
yeah it's interesting how this just transitioned
to a position where it's a pretty clear extra
pawn i thought that black would have some huge
compensation but as i look at the position it
seems like it's just a stable extra pawn and i'm
not sure where yon is going to have sufficient
compensation yeah three degree degree degree um
when we first you know we're talking
about the position i thought black
had compensation on the default one of
those kind of typical positions but now
even moves like queen b6 can be met by bishop
a3 so there's no like you know there's no way
to create more than one problem here black
would love to have you know a pin on the d
file you've got the pressure on the palm but
i think lavon will just play bishop a3 here
and he's like you said he's gotten out of
dodge and has an extra pawn and indeed he does
and these are the positions that are very
frustrating for black because if a queen
trade is offered even if it comes to the cost of
doubling white's pawns you're like wait there is
still that extra pawn that remains so queen b3 for
instance you don't want to take on b3 you don't
want to trade those queens you're just down pawn
and he plays queen c2 keeping his queen closer
and taking control over this the second
rank because black would have enjoyed
planting a rook on e2 himself it just looks like
a clean extra pawn to me at this point a to d1
start tradies and pieces and hey push forward
it's a smooth it's a smooth victory right now um
and okay i mean the drawing chances
are not completely out of the woods
you know if you could get if you get into a rook
ending we know that those are not always the
easiest thing to convert or even a queen ending
but no matter what ending it's a white playing for
two results because of this extra pawn and dawn
has some things to figure out in the first date
i mean just if we're totally honest because he's
taken an approach that again if you're just tuning
in where have you been robert's very angry with
you that you're late but um john has not played
his main line stuff all day as white he's been
rocking a b3 system it's black he's been playing
you know some different kind of sicilians so if
he falls behind by two games in the match what is
the tipping point where he's like all right i got
to win this thing it's time to go for some main
line theory here and use my prep i don't know if
that moment will ever come but i'm waiting for it
and i also want to mention that both kings have
some issues here that the rook on e8 needs to
stay there otherwise a background check would be
devastating because of the compromise dark squares
around black's king and for white your only
outlet is h2 but a timely bishop f4 could shake
things up so i i will say that both kings need
to be careful here queen a4 takes a7 that looks
ideal but lavon looks great so far in this
match no i agree good to highlight those
tactics those are things you got to be aware of
especially as time pressure ensues um but now
what do you play you probably bring the queen no
i was gonna say he probably should have brought
the queen back to defend the rook something about
this move is not not making uh the computer happy
i'm wondering is there some sort of tactic yeah
it's back rank mate queen h4 hits h6 and threatens
rook d8 what look at you eating your wheaties
doing your puzzle rush and making mama proud
let's show it on screen because we know she's
watching hi mom here we go queen h4 bam slam
jam you move the bishop i don't care where you
put it doesn't matter put that guy right there
i i mean you know oh we missed it like we need
four probably still a very good move but yeah i
mean okay look we see the position i was talking
about the back rank idea so i already had it
in my head and it doesn't hurt but being honest
doesn't hurt when you have the eval bar being like
hey dude there's a win just make the correct move
yeah this also eval barches coming to you from
chess.com in 2021 it's on the product roadmap
i made eric do it really yeah you're so proud
of yourself too that smile that was a full-on
i love it we'll call it ludwig chess help chess
i don't know what we're going to call it yet but
it's coming and i think it's going to be a really
interesting variant because you know what'll
happen robert psychologically you'll have players
that without eval chess robert are both 1800
but then when you add the eval bar one of them
is 2 000 and one of them is like 2 200 and what
what might that suggest about that player like
they lack confidence right it's a psychological
thing so i think there's actually an instructive
element to playing chess as long as you remove
the eval we don't want the email or announcing
mate it's just the bar telling you right i think
that that's a super interesting way to do it
and without like it's not fair if the eval bar
says hey you have mate and six that's not what
we're doing right but just you know letting you
know who's better both players so it'll be a lot
of fun i can't wait i have a very important
question for you first question will i see
queen h4 and find that back rank mate and second
question do you think i will ever play eval chess
yes you will okay sure whoa wait there's a pin
down the d file that was cool whoa what's going
on here oh bishop takes f8 bishop of fate uh
bishop takes up and you win the brook on b8 yeah
lavon's winning yawn is cursing great view into
the man bun though he is clearly letting his soul
glow back there right yes but he's not very happy
about what just transpired because yeah look at
well him should be and again i mean that was a uh
it was a rough result he's now down by two games
after after winning the first game not in the
match they drew the first but after taking the
first decisive game jan has not not been able to
get a dub ever since and is now down four to two
um and wow where's the uh next game yeah so
i'm wondering what's going on with these guys
where's the rematch two went for a
quick break now they're not rematching
maybe they forgot how to rematch they know how
this works they've been doing this for years
i'll check with the team um hey someone
named danny just subscribed look at that
and it wasn't you what says someone named
danny just subscribed and it wasn't you oh
cool here we go danny there we
go all right we have liftoff um
shout out to all those of you still playing
guess the move we have a lot of title players
indian lad given dragon b70 who normally dominates
a run for his money so that's a lot of fun
if you don't know what guess the move is go to
chess.com and play you can keep the show going
right don't leave us we want you here with us
in fact sometimes our commentary might even help
you guess the right move rarely at least mine not
roberts let's be honest that guy um anyway but uh
open cash prizes playing against the move robert
for sure we have our first e4 by john when
when you stopped talking about random things
that you know about i was going to mention that
as soon as you shut the all right uh i
will shut the front door let's back up to
the analysis board and show the opening jan has
played 1b3 all day not anymore he's down by two
games i said that he would switch back to main
line you said he wouldn't guess who was right
wait when did i say that oh i did say that you're
right admit it you heard that i said you were
right thank you and the position that we have
on the board right now i didn't hear what you
said but i could hear that you were mumbling
something trying to get past me what'd you say
don't go drink your coffee what did you say i
didn't say anything i was now you're lying to
the whole all right queen night goodnight
to f3 and yon is a little better as white
better the positions that he's been
getting um can i take the pawn though um
you can't but you drop b5 so it's an interesting
trade here as black's pawn structure right now is
worse because black has these double pawns but
that transition will give up your essential e4
pawn for one of the double pawns and leave black
with that isolated queen pawn so it is a very
interesting choice here i think yan's position is
much easier to play but don't count levon out here
as if he could open up the queen side he has a
bishop pair bishops work well on both sides of the
board in a way that a knight doesn't because the
knight is a slower piece just in how it moves so
i think that the longer the this game goes if the
position can open up levon has some chances but
i really like john's position out of the opening
for sure and well said and the long-term features
i think do favor black but i'm i'm a little
more skeptical of black's king side maybe than
than you are at least and you sounded because i
don't know i just feel like there's got to be some
way to get surgical up in this i mean lavon
plays f6 really a little worried i although
it does i guess it just stops knight g5 so you
know you start thinking of ways to break through
right ways to bring pieces over to the side
of the board levon plays f6 to slow it down
but i think jan's response is very instructional
because when your opponent has a bishop pair if
you can trade off the bishop that you have
for example now take on b6 you have a knight
your opponent has a light square bishops the
dark squares are now yours so if he does trade
in fact there puts it he's gonna put a knight on
d4 and that knight can never be kicked out of this
beautiful central square right a centralized
knight often just as good as a bishop even in
open positions and john's gonna have quite the
night on d4 but i like this move check cause
he's gonna he's gonna immediately go after the d6
pawn i think just put a rook on d1 yeah and here
he goes i think i think yawn had had his enough
of not getting an advantage with the first move
and has gone back to some main line openings
and trying to get this back to within the game
and his position is excellent he's up a clean pawn
he's much better here but i do think lavonda the
best thing that he possibly could is he gave up
the pond well he didn't have a choice at that
point but still sometimes you give up a pawn to
try to get full development and look what he's
done he has made white's king a little bit weaker
he has made that pawn structure on white king's
head compromised and white's dominating there's
no questions about that but he's giving himself
chances as this game continues yup i'm yupping
you right now yeah i know and i didn't like it
i haven't gotten to yup someone
in a while you just got yupped
um you're you're not a yuppie but you wish you
were um e5 has been played yawn shook his head
there i'm curious why i think he's still better
right it looks it looks kind of smooth and i did
want to back up and just you know with our jokes
aside it was such an instructive point robert
highlighted with bishop g4 because so many people
will will die trying to defend bad positions but
this is the practical thing you want to start to
develop in your chess game recognize when things
have gone wrong right you give yourself these
practical chances that you wouldn't otherwise have
and i think that even if you know white is up a
pawn and obviously yawn is better in a blitz game
where your opponent you know doesn't always have a
lot of time you've opened your opponent's king and
those are the kind of practical chances you
might need although as i say you don't have
a lot of time look at yon's time compared to
lavon's uh this is what we've seen pretty much
every game is yawn with the lead on the clock
not this much though this is as bad as it gets
for lavon because this is it kind of reminds me
of classical chess honestly where you've played
a long game now you're down into a position that's
better for white but you're hoping to survive as
black but you have no time and you just have spent
too much in the earlier stages yeah but i i would
love to just like keep your pawns double than the
f file but i know that if i move my rook from e8
to f8 for example there could be some f5 and whose
king is weaker at that point it looks like blacks
but maybe what it can be turned around and white's
king could get some trouble so he does just that
i don't know yeah i'm with you it's it ended up
being a weird double-edged finish with both kings
open and the major pieces on the board double
death bonds are not the the prettiest thing to
look at so i guess from lavon's defensive point
of view if he can just kind of sit tight maybe
he has better drawing chances even just in the
rook ending yes i'll put queen of six i guess
i had a necessity just more than anything like i
said get to the rook ending yeah and those pawns
are bad and if you look at the queenside pawns
it's a three on three on the queen side despite
the fact that black's pawns are doubled and on
the king side you don't really have a passport
the way you would like but that's a good move
rook d7 yeah this was instructive everybody
because what john's saying is exactly to prove me
and robert wrong if you take i will take with the
pawn and now i'm doing now i'm looking fancy and
feeling fancy you sure are vaseline yeah this this
is a good move you maintain the tension try to get
black to take and fix your structure how is the
king of pawn in the game though like if rook f7
can you oh he doesn't play vertical seven because
it won't happen now but
that's an interesting question
and okay so how to go forward from here you can
trade on f6 and take on b7 but that will only
be one extra pawn in a rook end game and those are
notorious for being uh giving the side that's down
upon great drawing chances so i don't know if he
wants to take on f6 here and he has plenty of time
so i would advise using some of it right you would
advise john to use it you and every coach that
he's had since his childhood and you know what he
said to a lot of those coaches i don't need time
i'm young upon machine um and guess what he didn't
need to take his time he just went for the queen
c7 he's probably right yes because after queen f4
and that's why we have rook h8 which is a very sad
move to play yeah he could have taken on h7 then
traded queens and then taken on b7 two extra pawns
in the rook in the game should suffice let's
just from a practical point of view everybody
i'll applaud yon real quick that regardless of
the fact that he's criticized sometimes we're
playing too fast when you have this kind of time
it often is wise to just keep the position as is
don't give any clarity right because the easiest
moves for your opponent to play are the forcing
moves the recaptures when you check they just
move right so keep the position look at yep and
oh he made that move but the point is a lot harder
to play this position with no time and indeed he
converts because of it so i think even if the
the queen trader rook ending was winning this
was the right decision by yon and he's brought it
back to within a game as he takes a sip of that t
i think that's a very good point
danny that you made there is
when your opponent has mere seconds on the clock
and you are well ahead we're half joking when we
say take your time because there are moments
in classical games as well where young plays
too quickly and it backfires but it is in those
moments where you are pressuring your opponent
on the board and on the clock you don't want
to simplify allow them several quick moves
and that gives them the ability to figure out the
position hey danny we have your favorite opening
mine is i was just going to say after applauding
yawn's last game i have to turn my nose in disgust
but you know you like these lines way more
than most of the others yeah these lines are
exciting though this is the poison pond right
this is what i'm this is what i'm all about um
the winner and the poison pawn not seen at the
highest levels every day anymore it was all the
rage in the in the 90s but we'll do back up real
quick just set the tone of what this french is all
about ooh because h4 i haven't seen that one in a
while oh boy the widower is defined with this move
bishop b4 in the french the basic dynamic quickly
is that black will get positional advantages on
the queen side in exchange for having parted ways
with his dark square bishop the white immediately
exposes that with things like queen g4 and in
these variations uh the main line after knight bc6
is actually to play the move f4 to protect e5 and
then bring the queen back um but yawn plays h4
not the most commonly traveled road and now
queen d3 the risk of these lines is that e5 falls
but what white's saying in these variations
is look i even if i'm not up upon i still have
a past pawn right so in a lot of the poison pawn
white is trying to keep that pawn which is why
it's called the poison pond here white gave
it back you're gonna win c3 and try to just
win on the dark squares you'll notice that
there's no variation of the french robert
that i don't like for white i even like this i
like the main line poison pawn and i like this
this is a much sharper variation compared to
others yeah and i think i need to do myself a
favor and give my good friend tatsu abrahamian a
phone call she exclusively plays the french and
uh the amount of winners she's had in her career
but she would like yawn's position here and as
much as i i got my you know i got my punches in
i like white in every variation the more
i'd look at this position i'm like yawn
uh he went with the frenchy dirty dog but why
do you live on play h4 i mean the main lines
are the main lines are good enough you don't got
to go for that but just play the main line you
know what it could be danny and as amazing
as a player as lavon is of course sometimes
when you play openings that you don't play
regularly you make mistakes in the early theory
and you forget i do think that the position's
still playable but you play move like h4 you're
like wait was that the right time to do that or am
i now allowing black to just get a good position
yup you okay there you i think you're frozen
because you're just so displeased at the french
so i'm just pleased with the
position while i got here
don't forget your lines and then i can forgive
you right i forget but never forgive that's how
that's supposed to go i'm pretty sure to forgive
is divine i don't remember but you get it you
hold a mean grudge look at you yeah but you
know what's interesting about this danny is
like what is black's plan black's pieces are
perfectly placed are you just gonna go e4 e3 are
you gonna like do something like that to me you're
gonna push your pawns black has so many good plans
in these positions this is the problem with the
white side of the poison pond is this king is
never safe black gets safe but the castle is long
so when you've allowed the center to be you know
not even just undermined here just you know taken
by black this is super tough for for white because
even exchange sacks are always on the agenda and
you have these end games where the e pawn is super
strong um i like your idea of e4 and e3 in fact
i love that idea as much as i hate saying that
i just feel like what's going right for white and
the answer might be nothing yeah the only thing
that's that's right is harry over here you're a
wizard we'll see if he can pull something magical
out of his you-know-what but i don't think
so i think i think yawn is going to tie this
match and by the way will we get one more
five minute game let's look at the clock
oh i didn't even think about that i
feel like we'll get one more after this
that's my guess what just happened there
bishop e4 was a blunder and that must be why
pawn was hanging oh my gosh i still like black
forget it but well knight's coming to c4 though
oh that's the fork that he missed he was
threatening a fork of the king and bishop
okay what is happening here
so you can play rook h2
or rook g1 i don't know which is better but
that's something that needs to be figured out
i'm like something tells me those
playing guess the move in this game
robert are not going to get a very high percentage
this is not indian he's playing and so is dragon
b70 so you know knight to c4 okay he's just giving
up h1 to go knight d6 check and take b7 well you
can also just take a5 true too much to think about
damn my head hurts you didn't pay me for this
yeah this is this is a head hurting position um
yawn does have a little more time to think it
through whether he uses it or not is always the
question um would you go so far say this is
a pretty critical moment of the entire match
because it's a one point lead for lavon and yeah
you're right knight takes a five just looks good
especially because yawn had just won that last
game right so if lavon immediately responds and
maintains a two-game lead i think that in a match
that we expect is going to come down to the wire
and bullet you and i say this a lot right this
is this is a a moment where we won't be talking
about this one as much as the bullet because it's
always you know what you remember last right but
these moments here could be just as deciding
to the match as as what happens in the end
knight takes a5 was played and uh i like
aronian's position the french will go down
i don't hear anything uh oh we have disconnections
we have robert here
we lose internet oh i can
robert yeah that's on you guys it's our internet
wait now you're back i think maybe
are the players legit fine
oh they're fine and we're back wow and now i hear
you again and everyone heard us the whole time
if you guys didn't see my face i have my
oh face and i also have my your god is my
live server crashing fake um but it doesn't
look like it is that was uh that was strange
well uh you know maybe what's going on
mickey recipes danny but i will take
awkward chess broadcast moments for 400 please
awkward just broke he once made it awkward just
so he could say he knew how it feels who said that
diana naraditsky but also the most interesting man
in the world yeah um okay f3 played by lavon
and still looks to be good i guess he's up
the exchange but this is not an exchange where
you know you're converting easily right robert
this is uh especially with only 30 seconds
on the clock this is a really weird position
it is but let's do a you know there's an extra
exchange the h pawn that's a clear passer and
the bishop on h1 is such a problematic piece and
oh there's some knight d4 ideas oh very nice oh my
gosh wait you could take on e2 and then go knight
d4 check but i don't know if you can catch the h
pawn oh the h pawn to the batcave let's show it
the analysis board it turns out harry is a wizard
and if you go for this you can't stop me oh
wait you can play bishop takes e5 before we
should be five first freaking sick if that doesn't
highlight the the bishop's dominance over a knight
nothing will so yawn can't that's
that's really nasty everybody i mean d3
this was a wild wild idea here by lavon to
allow queen takes e2 because of the h pawn so
if he goes on to win this game it might be
because of that tactic but look at look at
depot he's keeping it yeah he managed to
make his way back in this one here and even
the pressure yeah i think levon's time trouble
is really costing him at this moment because
uh it seemed like he was in good shape levant
threw excuse me jan threw in that check and
caught levon probably off guard a bit and now
that bishop one h1 is alive and well and yeah
actually quite a strong piece whoa in fact now
he's just giving back the exchange practically a
draw for obscure bishops yeah that's what you call
a decision made because of time trouble as right
under 20 seconds he's like i don't want to risk
this let me just force this into an equal position
yeah rook takes e5 was saying i feel like this is
a game that i'm going to lose in the time scale
and maybe not the worst practical decision
right they are human beings after all
not just computers and i think now yawn is making
that decision do i want to keep the time scramble
alive try to swindle myself something with
only 16 seconds or do i just take the draw
nope he wants to swing five i'm pushing that
pawn push him baby there's just no mating
net that black can come true here i just yeah the
problem for yawn is like how do you actually make
tricks because the queen defends the bishop
very hard for me to make a blunder here right
queen's defensive bishop bishop defends the queen
right i mean unless i walk into mate there's no
blunders coming yeah i mean i was blunderful with
my vocabulary it's a construe and i was like what
am i talking about i might configure it but anyway
vocabulary what'd you say no don't worry about it
danny don't worry about it anyway so this looks
like a offer a piece note that the eight pawn
the a1 square does not match black's bishop so all
white needs to do is trade off the bishop for the
b-bond to force his driver i hope that's what he
does or is it just sack and then put the king here
yeah that's what he should do he's a draw and
this will officially be the last game of the
five minute portion it took a long time and
he does it yes robert has his dreams are alive
there they are for those tuning in we got 10
000 of you on twitch and about 5 000 on youtube
thanks for being here you didn't know this
was a draw the reason is that the bishop
can't force the king out of the opposite color
corner so it doesn't matter what you have even
when you win the pawn you cannot win an end game
with a wrong color corner bishop even with an
extra pawn and and minor piece so fun fact if you
didn't know robert i stole your thunder there um
i'll forgive you eventually but we we have a
one game match and we'll check in with what
our smarter chess predictions said in a minute and
uh see what we think uh will happen as these two
players face the faster segments today but right
now we have our next primetime smackdown coming up
um i don't even remember who it was if
this is my match versus john bartholomew
or john's match versus eric rose we've had a
lot of these going on they've been a ton of fun
but um if it's my match versus bartholomew you
are in for a treat i'm gonna say that um if it's
frozen and bartholomew it's probably lame you
should probably leave right now let's be honest
those guys not rocking the the biggest personality
stuff am i still on air okay let's go to break
all right john you want to start us off hey guys
this is john and my uh semi-annual beatdown of
international master danny wrench vice president
of chess.com happy to be here with you today oh
man that's hilarious okay i was giving you the
opportunity hey guys i mean off the camera i
already told everybody i told the team that's
recording this that i would rather take black
first just to avoid your damn scandinavian okay
and what i said in reply is you don't have to
play e4 well i'm going to we'll see what happens
in the match okay like you said all right anyway
john great to see you man and uh here we go this
is gonna be a ton of fun um be gentle all right
just kidding don't be gentle best of five one
minute let's do this levy the other day told
so told me that somebody paid him to keep
the match close i was like whatever dude
that's not even true when did you start playing
the tory i mean or the the you haven't been paying
attention to my games over the past couple years
it has been a while since we played hasn't it been
it has we used to do chess rivals and then some
yup yup which was a ton of fun agreed i would say
we should bring that back but i've got enough
pain in my life why would i put myself in that
um yeah what are you doing we already have
like three kids so i don't know if i need
a kid in my life yeah possible adoption
again wouldn't that be uh oops yeah that
was a bishop wasn't it you didn't see it
i'll take it can i do this i'm doing it
oh okay don't know what's going on but i'm doing
it sharp stuff hey not the first time that i've uh
wait i think that actually worked i i
definitely thought that rook was defended on d1
not gonna lie to you guys okay so did i
um but hmm i'll take it what are you doing
don't do things
i'm gonna lose this first no
clean sweep no clean sweep
nice i mean i'm just i'm i'm with you and how
shocked you feel right now my heart goes after
you your strategy of giving me white in the first
game is already paid psychologically i avoided the
scandinavian beatdown now now i'm gonna play d4
and if somehow that leads to a victory i put you
in a where a lot of people are against against
me which is just you know all you have to do is
win a few games it's not that hard against me
there you go oh that's a good point though i
have my back against the wall already yeah you
have my back against the walls have you said
i was saying my back but all right here we go i i
told you before we started uh i don't know if this
is gonna air i'm not in charge of the production
but if this airs before the match with levy
if you will know i almost
beat levy in a match twist
i'm the i'm literally the almost didn't
almost doesn't count guy you have to
keep reminding him of that what is going on
here driving me crazy with your good moves
yeah you're the guy who like nearly
won the state championship ball
oh my gosh what did you do what are you
doing i was oh man why did you pre-move that
i don't know i don't know what you were doing
dude ah mine okay this is the scenario we didn't
want dude this is the this has never happened
to me i gotta i gotta replay it how did that
happen how did what did you do with the pre-move
let's see knight knight d2 queen d3 knights knight
e4 yeah i played knight d1 out of pure desperation
defense and you pre-moved rook c3 i guess i didn't
predict that you would play a move that bad i know
so
and we are back here the speed chess championship
rolls on as do all of the guests of movers this is
a snapshot of the last game of the five minute
portion we saw dragon b70 overtake grand master
indian lad but will it be the money game remember
when the entire match is over we randomly choose
one of the games that has been played throughout
the whole day so you have not missed your chance
yet and just because there are others on the
leaderboard before you literally gives them
no more chance than you to win the
cash prizes or the premium memberships
just fun to see all the different title players
playing so head over play guess the move uh
try to learn some chess from yondu palm machine
lavon ironian and maybe win some cash along the
way speaking of yonder palm machine levon roni and
robert smarter chess predictions actually did have
lavon taking the edge in the 5 1 portion not quite
by by two games but if if that stays the course
then yawn is about to bounce back here yeah and
lavon you know he was kind of close to making it
a two-game spread but lavon extremely young held
well there in the end and i must say smart chess
doing a decent job but john is favoring the
quicker time patrols and if these predictions
hold true then john's in great shape to win
this match as he is only down one game as we
head into three minute plus one second increment
time segment yama 3-2 in the twitch chat that's
an interesting request that we've actually
gotten multiple times the problem with how
allowing multiple move like pre-moves while you're
playing guess the move is a lot of times you guess
the move and then you maybe change your mind
before they've moved and so you need to click
and go away so it's not exactly easy to build
in multiple guesses built up like we allow for
multiple premiums when you're playing guess the
move so i saw that same request earlier in chess
tv so i'm acknowledging it but i don't know if
it's something that is actually possible to do so
anyway but appreciate you playing and appreciate
the request appreciate nine thousand plus of you
on twitch we've still got six thousand of you
over on youtube right now the party has just begun
i think we're in for a nail biter and here we go
the three minute is about to start we have liftoff
and let's see young gets the white pieces will
there it is e4 so he realizes this whole b3 stuff
not working out for him in this oh oh no
we have berlin stuff going on but this is fun
last time oh now we've got a a very open game
here for black this is a you know we always
call d3 the ante berlin not because it actually
that's not the actual name of it but it avoids
the main line theory and gives robert hope for
the future of life so we love that we love the
auntie berlin robert's not a big berlin guy
look at how theoretical this line is it's
really hard to get everything acknowledged but
if we just take a quick look with an analysis
board after black made the ninth move castle
um it looks like a5 just traps the bishop on b6
because that was the whole point of white's play
was it not to go a5 and trap it but i believe that
there's like a bishop takes f2 check and e4 move
like it's a very complicated position and i don't
know all the ins and outs i just know that black
is not giving away a piece for free yeah the crazy
line the king is forced to walk directly into the
face of danger here and um not something that
that white likes so knight bd2 is played instead
still a5 is a possibility but yawn declines
it yet again to play bishop a3 which threatens
things like b5 so these guys know their theory e4
is played anyway and with the position opening up
in the end the trade frees the bishop that you're
not losing it but white is a little bit better
probably in the end game i guess because of the
the d-pawn but maybe not actually wait i mean
things over here that are falling yeah
yeah i think most of the high-level games
that have played this line have just
resulted in a draw surprise surprise
but white does look a bit better in terms of
pawn structure because if you look at the d6 pawn
that's more weakness but it's not really going to
amount to much if i remember correctly ray robson
essayed this opening against wesley so in
the u.s championship recently concluded
championship so um not all that much happening
in terms of novel ideas at this point
yeah i wish i would say about this i did refill
my coffee if you're wondering i was deeply curious
anyway all right so 95 is a trade
of d-pawn for c-pawn potentially
um the weird position because normally
this this whole queen side expansion is
all aggressive for white and and this king
is you know resting on the king side but not
not the case in this line um it's starting to
look bad for white yeah i'm sorry like black
it's a beautiful square and then you just
took a pawn so yep what's john's idea here
yon gives the old you know we call that
yonder pop yonda pandushi head nod number four
and what does that tell us besides you know
flaunting that means i know i'm worse but
i'm already here might as well keep playing
chess i actually say that's a pretty accurate
assessment of his head bob and then that's diana
palmer and she look over the shoulder number seven
pretending like there's something that i heard
but that's just because i'm bored and i don't
like to think of my opponent's clock you want
me to keep translating every facial expression
well lavon hasn't really had too many facial
expressions so we're you know yacht is the only
place you can go i think you're doing a great
job all right well black is better here jokes
aside i mean and right now if lavonne stole
that pawn and white doesn't get it back then
then uh bond is a pawn right um here do not take
on e3 because the knight will recapture with
a fork on the rooks but what you can do is play
rook to e1 and if the bishop takes on c1 then you
can consider taking on e8 and taking this knight
on c4 so you can transition instead of having the
same pieces in the end game you can say i like
the prospects of my knight more than your dark
sport bishop yeah and he goes for that we might
see it on the board nope lavonne recognizes that
the end game is let's analyze that real quick
because robert's line was was instructive one
of those rare times where you could actually
go into an end game up a pawn and be worse
you know with white's king being so active
the d-pawn being weak i would i would think
that white is doing well here um although maybe
black house counter plays so either way lavonne
doesn't like the transition he plays rookie six
maintaining the steering contest here on e3 and c1
and i think lavon is you know he's put himself in
another good spot i agree with you and g2 is now
under attack uh there is some difficulty here
if you take on g2 then once the rook capturing
e6 the d-pawn would have been hanging but
now the knight on c4 protects that pawn
which i think is a very good decision by
lavon here but a5 is a nice response by yon
yeah i i like the way that yawn is playing this
even though he's a little worse because if there's
any misstep there's any slight wrong transition
like maybe what we're seeing now these advanced
pawns if we get like a quick trade suddenly become
aggressive you know aggressive potential new
queens so you have to be really careful if you're
erroneous he's up a pawn but it's a weak d6 pawn
but levon's actually handling
this excellently and i think that
you wanted to boot this knight from c4 but somehow
it remains a thorn in yon's side here a6 just to
not hang your a7 pawn d6 is protected by that very
knight on c4 so levon's extra pawn would live yeah
h5 okay about equal on the clock so the three
minute portion not revealing anything yet
so knight comes e5 now this f7 pawn if it wants
can go to f5 but i wouldn't do that because
you should look at your base pawns where
could the weaknesses be if i push f7 then
g6 becomes looser so that's why the f pawn
will remain where it is keeping the pawn gene
good point watch out for forks
he avoids that and now you
would like to keep the 95 but you'd also
like to move it out of the way to the rook
and watch out for b5 check at some point
there could be like a fork in the air
if if take everything you get a fork on c7
and if you back up there's a fork on f6 so
lavon now under the clock trying to
solve this problem did you miss b5
no it wouldn't i think he did it was king
c5 there was always king c5 just keeping
uh you safe there okay you have to watch out
here all right only a few seconds knight f6 check
is in the air okay couldn't couldn't get
away with it so but now black is defending
passively so you're up a pawn but your pawns
are kind of weak and you're in passive position
yep and you only have a few seconds that
night is tricky it is indeed night is tricky
e6 that could be a move that pushes
too far though for yon because now
now you've deadlocked things and
your pawns are also very weak i agree
and he missed it oh and i don't
know what john said but it wasn't pg
oh man and again he's just shaking his head oh wow
that was painful yeah that that that wasn't good
it felt like b6 was pushing a little too far
honestly it felt like he should have settled on
the fact that he had been worse most of the
game down a pawn acknowledge what was so
and and keep the tension like the moment we bring
up the analysis board the moment he played b6
i was just like ah that's how good positions
you go a little too far i think because
you know you had all the tension here you could
have just repeated with a draw they'd already
repeated once but instead he plays the move
b6 and lets the king come up and now it was
white who was really full of targets lavon did
not have to be asked twice to grab the g file
and even even if he doesn't blunder the exchange
like he's already i mean 93 check is coming and
night see i mean just to show robert there was
like awkwardness like this right with mates
i mean this was advancing those pawns
was not a good idea and he pays the price
yeah you actually called it completely when you
said hey this b6 move that's it and it's in this
notion of a backward pawn the pawn a5 quickly
became a target and much easier to attack when
you release the tension and it's a good lesson
in tension as well but right now danny we do
have a french i actually like black's position i
don't really think that white is breaking through
anytime soon and if that's the case look down
that c file look at those double c pawns and
also the f5 square it's a light square you only
have a dark square bishop so if that knight can
quickly get to f5 if you could put the knight
right now at f5 black would be in great shape
yeah let's bring up the analysis board
to show where levon varied if you're
just joining us the last game of the five
minute portion was the same exact position
in the traditional widower lavon went for the main
line with queen g4 in this game he played seven
h4 which is a line uh not as not as well known
um but ultimately dawn seemed prepared for it
defends against the rushing h-pawn and then what
happens is if white fails to deliver anything on
the missing dark square bishop which is kind of
the overarching theme of the winower then it's
only a matter of time before you're positionally
worse on the queen side as robert said and so
i'm kind of with you this doesn't look
like a line that had a lot of bite
it's still always double-edged because forever you
have the potential dark squares if you're white
but i'm with you that in a rare in a rare
sense that almost never comes out of my mouth
i like this position for black in the
french and look at that move after queen g3
g7 most of us react oh my pawn's under attack
let me protect it but there were tactical flaws
in protecting it with sacrifices so he puts in 97
defends it tactically rather than directly because
knight coming to f5 just like we talked about
danny that's a light square you have a dark square
bishop you cannot kick this night out this is a
great position for yon i agree i think i think
yawn is maybe finding the opening he's going to
keep playing for because even though that poison
pawn got weird and maybe lavon was better right i
mean jan had a good position there lavon clearly
not on the cutting edge of his theory here
on the white side of these of these winnowers
i mean not no no you know offense intended but
at least in terms of the lines he's been choosing
this is not positions we've liked for white oh
not at all because whether or not you keep these
double c pawns on the board or you trade on d4
and open up the c file for your rook and queen
to barrel down black's position looks quite
safe there are no weaknesses the knight on f5
is so strong not only attacking the d4 square but
defending g7 pretty much permanently and the rook
on g4 kind of needs to share the square with a
pawn can't do that sorry not allowed and if that's
the case then black should be able to uh get it
out of this and here comes queen c4 isn't trade
questions you just invented a new variant share
the square sharing is caring cheer the square
share the square no but i know many times
i've wanted to share the square of my life
like you you you said it so well you want the pawn
to kick the knight but but you actually don't want
the pawn there because then you want to move it
back and have the rook here right so share the
square somebody called my agent i don't have
an agent oh yeah that's right back to the game
queen c4 all right um yeah lavonne is definitely
on the worst side of this french um the rook comes
up the d-pawn's weak this is the opposite of what
the potential of your dark square bishop is and
on the white side of a winter world this is now
you're just you know you're staring at uh you're
staring at hot air right there's nothing to
do with these squares this king is going to
come up the rook joins the queen side the great
position for black yeah and the one thing that
black really does need to be careful about is not
moving the king away and allowing g4 because the
f7 pawn does need some defense but a typical move
thematic idea is g5 or g6 here for black saying
your pawn h5 is a huge thorn in my side so let
me push through and try to actually open up the
side because my pieces are ready to
start countering okay well he goes g4
unfortunately he will not be sharing the
square we have not invented that yet but
but lavonne is is trying to prove us wrong and
say wait a second guys there's some long-term
features here my bishop does eventually
find a purpose i still believe i don't
care what computers say i mean i feel like
this is a position that only black can win
uh because of the weaknesses because of the the
french structure um but i will admit it's become a
little tricky for black robert because you can't
quite coordinate without the f palm being weak
this and if you can't do that robert then
the rook is out of play so this is a little
bit tricky right here yeah and i would say one
big idea for white is to play a5 at the right
moment to open up the queen side and if you
respond to a5 to keep the position closed b5
then white thrusts that pawn to a6 yeah and leaves
the a7 pawn stuck on a dark square where it can
be attack later but nope that's not happening
for sure probably that lavon is four seconds
what oh we've been blocked in the world of chess
we forgot we got other problems here one second
oh boy you gotta play c3 and then hope for the
draw right defense so if there was something there
he clearly didn't have the time to press lavon is
officially back where we thought he'd be which is
fighting for a draw on this worst end game in the
french and now f6 you that's the move your yawn
it is a thematic move it's a strong move it tries
to chisel the center but also in your opponent's
time trouble very hard to meet yep yeah and as a
latest says in the chess tv chat it's important
to note that yawn chose the french and the
candidates he did but he also got smashed by mbl
in the french in the candidates so that was
probably not a good decision of the candidates
i wasn't going to bring that up but i'm glad you
did because it's good to remind people that just
because he did it doesn't mean he remembers it
doesn't mean it's although i think i think he may
keep going to it today lattice and chess tv so
you're not wrong but in the candidates a little
bit different um i think he's going to get this
one though this is so tricky for white rook c4
you got to run you have to play a5 for
white i think it's your only chance
look at that b5 bring the rook back this is not
the same position where you have a dark square
bishop going after the pawn but it's not so easy
for black to win i know that he's well on the
clock but lavon's doing a really good job here
like props to him if he can get an attack on the
a7 pawn he could even turn this thing around not
going to happen and think about it oh rook b2 now
yeah nice king f1 oh or losing time on uh
the time pressure finally caught up with him
what was the final evaluation of that position
i mean i know black was better but if we bring
it up we've got king f1 how does black win
you just trade on g2 and then probably yeah
yeah i guess so that's actually okay back to
the current game and and back to some main
line theory by the way uh plays he plays d6
this time around rather than the d5 line yeah
although that might be because jan castle right
in the other game the king didn't castle so it's
these slight move order changes that can be
very confusing for most players myself included
and well what's happened so e4 is hanging
that's why he did this and now he protected e5
wow danny what do you make of this opening knights
in g6 we don't really love them often but maybe
we're a little too harsh we're a little too harsh
on those nights yeah during those donkeys a night
in front of a g or a b-pawn loses his cred he's
back to a donkey no but jokes aside in this
structure it's not going to mean it's not going
to stay this way that's black's whole idea you're
building up a transition to open the position
and you need all the pony support you can get um
it's not quite the same i'm sorry i was
distracted by the live chest chat i'm always
i always love when members tune in
because people who watch these shows
think oh like how does everyone not know
the sec is going on people tune in like
let's go why are so many people watching
this game is this a tournament or something
and somebody else is like yeah i think
they're playing for like a thousand bucks
just awesome i love that the chess world is so
big people don't give a crap about this show
and i mean i'm looking now at the
chat as well i see the indian lad
still crushing it yeah still crushing it would
guess the move um all right so the transition
in the center happens in these italian games i
think we're going to have a little bit you know
for those who tuned in early enough to see that
yawn was avoiding theories white time to start
getting your notebooks out if you're one of the
more advanced players watching the show because
my guess is they are engaging now
in some much more relevant theory
but beyond mine and robert's you know level
of chess prep these days i'll say that
but this doesn't look very good for uh for
one like you've just given up the bishop
pair okay bishop g6 trademarks what oh look
at the f takes that was essential and maybe
that's what i i didn't see that coming and that's
clearly what yon missed yeah because oh man go
ahead no yo you finished the sentence what was
i'm on the edge of my seat let's analyze go ahead
yeah the point was you took with the h
pawn right then queen the a check comes in
and you're all tied down you're all out of
sorts back here i wouldn't even take on d4
i just my knight c4 bring my knight towards your
king and try to mate you with an eventual knight
g5 check right you're just that's such an
instructive point and i think as you said
that's what john missed because when lavon took
here you could see he paused and levon's idea i
guess was just queen of f8 right right and then
the bishop pair reigned supreme over the nights
robert you're so good at teaching chess i
mean you almost sound like you were saying
it sarcastically as if there's no child talking
to you accidental teaching moment by robert hess
um rookie i do love that i appreciate it no
announcements bishops exactly dirty dog bishops
look at queen of four oh no okay the brook was
hanging but i was i was trying to figure out a
way to threaten mate and defend the bishop and
attack the knight but okay what do you see sex
just getting into a slightly better ending
but i don't actually don't think this is
as much as you would hope for it's better for
black but probably not on the cusp of winning
like in some of the other lines that if yon and
misplayed he would have ventured into by mistake
yeah probably we're just headed toward equality
two well bishop takes e3 okay that's a really
good move because you're you're at least
causing your opponent a little bit of stress with
that isolated pawn but i think ultimately you're
right danny just repeat you know you know what's
frustrating danny is that earlier f takes g6 was
necessary but in that final position you really
wish you were h takes g6 right yeah you have in
fact let's bring up the the analysis board just
to show what robert's talking about the main point
is that if you just in the final position if you
just flip the script of these pawns black actually
has very decent winning chances because this
this pawn is not only is it not passed anymore
meaning it's not a pawn that can run to a queen
for those who don't speak french a past pawn
has nobody who can stop him this would make that
not a past pawn but it also would mean that that
the pawn is a bigger weakness right than it is now
so interesting point that f takes jesus because
you said robert was necessary and ultimately
limited winning chances that uh often is the
case i feel like but whoa so g2 hanging but bishop
e4 would be the resp what's what is this wait what
a g2 okay so he's just saying the bishop
pair is going to overwhelm you that's all
he's getting is the bishop pair as far as comp
goes he's down a pawn look but he's so much
development both bishops that knight coming
to b5 grook one happening castling queen side
this could just be a knockout lavon i feel
like why i feel like he surprises me so
often in the opening where it goes
things like this and then he's just
i don't know i i haven't seen this opening this
position in any other scc match yet this year
robert that's what i'm saying i feel like it's
just kind of a newer opening and lavon's about to
maybe stretch this thing back to a two-game lead
his position looks excellent it's just so many
ideas are clear for lavon with the white
pieces whereas john my ideas for black are
defensive knight a6 has stopped the fork on c7 he
plays it but now i see rook g1 you can't castle
because then i can take your knight in f6 and your
g pawn he gives up the g pawn but that can't just
give it back yeah i'm taking it again everybody
castles would have allowed all to show the quick
tactic no analysis board needed just show real
quick pin it to win it but yeah so white is
better you can even castle long here keep
the pressure i like it and what's he thinking
about so castling queen side he's not
going to take on f6 at least not yet
oh he might have some kind of knight d6
because the knight f6 isn't protected
so like like that hits f7 it sort of
forces a king takes d6 maybe and then
oh he does it robert yeah playing guess the
move bro what you can do at chess.com right
now win cash prizes and premium memberships
that's the move by robert hess i love that
you should always be looking at hanging pieces
and the knight on f6 is only defended by the king
so knight d6 in a sense it's a protected square
because you may give up your knight when you
win your opponent's knight and then knight
f6 is a crucial defender for the black king
oh it's a nathan f34r mod mod's
working hard thanks for all the support
instantly as soon as i did that little rant i was
going to guess the move yes the move command um
yeah that's an awesome move robert
jokes aside i mean seriously good find
it's just one of those positions danny from
as soon as black went up a pawn and we were
highlighting how white had more development
i start immediately thinking okay i'm down
material which he is no longer down material but
i start thinking about tactics because right the
black king is never going to find shelter
so let me try to go for for it all oh yikes
if you can't get a free sub boiling [ __ ]
you can just throw us your twitch prime and
watch the twitch primetime smackdown
right aptly named you're missing it
i'm currently engaged in a match with john
bartholomew at the break find out who wins
subscribe to the twitch channel um all right yeah
white's crushing it let's bring up the analysis
board uh because you you highlighted the opening
i think lavon is just brushing it here we were
also talking about the end of that rook ending
but again lavonne goes away for the first time
everybody from the mainline winter wars and i just
wanted to highlight because it's part of the match
storyline is these guys you know improve and show
the show the high level footwork of how they're
adjusting so he goes away from the mainline
win awards we've seen e5 in every other game
but he goes with bishop d3 and clearly got yawn
in some sideline he wasn't ready for because this
grab on g2 was not a good idea and as robert has
said white is just crushing in development and
as we catch up to the live game currently
crushing in the live position as well um
just awesome awesome chess here and lavon
might be about to jump back up by two games
and he's up two pawns at this moment so he started
down one that means he's taken three pawns in the
process of achieving this position here and all
right black has some chances because white's
pawn on the king side they're isolated and pawns
are best pushed with a pawn next to it because
the strongest pawn is one protected
by its buddy right because
you have to use a more valuable piece to attack
it so that's the problem that white is facing
but lavon is doing extremely well in the clock
danny that is a new thing that we haven't
seen much of yeah we we just saw several
people in chat all chats pointing that out
uh zen ottoman and the chess tv chat rocking that
premium membership i gave you from just a couple
matches ago because it's understandable for yon
to not want to play as candidates prep but against
aronian you know can he really do that um i think
he has switched into some mainline stuff now and
i think he'll continue to fight be willing to
play mainline stuff here on out ronian converting
sorry it was a chicken spammers
from the chat you know just
you were what everyday fun i was kicking
spammers from the chat so that's why i love that
when you moderate it gets me going i'll
tell you what you're moderating robert
hess is playing mod rolls all right you
cross the line you know usually you're
i don't know what's going on with me today the
accents have taken over oh man it's so good yeah
that i no look at that he leaves the king on the c
file so that the c2 pawn isn't hanging perfection
push up maybe push him baby yeah i was thinking
that too can you just push the pawn he's heat
lavon he's so practical he's like i'm
not even giving you any counter play
h pawn will win the game later
on he maintains a two-game lead
and i say maintains because he was up two points
jan struck back and now lavon regains that margin
but now young's gone back into
something weird no longer the uh
the e4 italian game we've been seeing but to
be fair it wasn't even just because uh you know
doesn't want to play main lines or something he
wasn't getting anything as white right in the
italian there that last game lavon played on the
black side of the italian was good for him so and
yeah this again has the carro con like pawn
structure with an exchange white has given up
the e pawn for black's c pawn and it looks
like that happened on the d5 square right
but in these two order positions you look at this
rook on c8 danny that semi-open c file seems more
valuable than the semi-open e file because the
e6 pawn defended by its friend on f7 the c2 pawn
is defended by a bishop but there are some loose
squares and here comes that knight potentially to
c4 and maybe knight e8 to d6 first i feel like
it's easier for black to play this position in
part because it is relatively closed and if it's
a closed positions knights often outplay bishops
yeah well said uh now what's interesting
is if you go knight c4 lavon is probably
considering just taking that
thing off the board um although
it's an interesting moment you kind of had to
move the knight because a5 was under fire so
no instead he maintains the tension he's going to
relocate the bishop to one of these diagonals also
knight to c5 is on the agenda so probably moving
this knight to either d7 or e8 makes sense here
yep indeed he doesn't and d4 is a problem so you
if you play c3 then instead of having your pawn
safely defended uh with the bishop now it's on
a potentially vulnerable square so i really like
the way levon is handling this and actually i like
that move from yan even though it doesn't threaten
anything this kind of re-maneuvering of your
pieces to coordinate better bring that rook over
towards the center or the king side there could
be a you know a g4 type of push in the future
indeed and now you see white's pieces
like they planned it all along joining
the party unfortunately black's
position is so solid that you know
you're still just kind of staring at a wall here
lavon offers the trade of the darksword bishops
okay the biggest issue for white long
term is this weak c pawn and yeah
um and and nepo do something with the pressure
on the king's side to kind of distract from that
being the main focus because notice what devon
is doing everybody he's getting surgical up in
this he trades the bishops now he's offering the
queen trades if pieces keep coming off the board
it's easy peasy to just focus in on the weak c
pawn and so kind of an instructive uh approach
there from the armenian right good good
anticipation of of the technique and and
what black really wants to focus on yeah because
as we were talking earlier look at what white's
rooks are doing doubled on a semi-open file
but they're still not doing anything because
e6 is so well defended by a pawn whereas look at
what levon is about to do double on the c file
and stare right down at the c3 pawn danny you
were just talking about that i think this position
might strategically be lost for white and you know
i don't mean i don't know he goes down three games
sorry robertson no i don't like talking in results
oriented um ways but it just looks so bad for
what at this point it's definitely a two result
position as they say everyone meaning black
is playing for a win but can only draw uh if it
doesn't work out and white is really it's much
worse than the computer is saying this is such a
hard position for white to hold oh this is such
a big moment can you take on c3 the answer was
the answer i was hoping you would have the answer
so to the batcave we go analysis let
me at least show the basic tactic if
you take with the knight there's knight to
be one but wait computer thinks black what
yeah because the work on c8 is
defended so you can play knight a2
oh sick x-ray vision defending
your knight through the enemy rook
and it only works because of what robert
pointed out that that rook is defended so
he's calculating that being aronian and he's going
to decide whether he can take here this is such
a huge moment it's winning if he sees it because
of knight a2 yeah this that was not my instinct
but you see the eval bar next to the board it's
saying black is fine better after knight takes
c3 it's like all right so what can it be and he
takes you to the rook on c3 which was my first
question was can i just do this and the answer
is yes this transition is not going to yield
as much for black i think partly because after
the the trades happen i think e4 is just weak
the king comes up quickly oh well now now it's
e4 is just being traded i thought he was going to
take c2 first yeah what was that decision yeah why
why didn't he take c2 first that that was weird
i thought he was going to take here
and take knight takes d6 instead
uh instead of taking back on
c2 was their knight takes d6 ah
maybe but that even that gives black okay
well obviously now we're in an end game
where things have recovered for the russian and
yawn likely likely not gonna go down three games
looks like he should hold but knights can be
very tricky in these end games but
look at the time advantage by the
way right like in another
extra minute position for young
he just can't win the knight's too strong on d6
up on he's up on the clock a lot yeah you know it
allowed us to be interesting if we talked to jan
after the match whether he thought that as long as
he was in a game or two he was still the favorite
and bullet we'll find out i mean right now i
don't think he's thrilled with his situation
and i don't i don't know that i would put him as
a two-game favorite and bullet maybe one game but
25 minutes we're going to find out what what
what happens when the fastest portion kicks in
and isn't it funny danny how you look
at these games so far and probably
our audience is like well clearly yan is the
better bullet player he moves much more quickly
but there are players alexander grishout
being chief among them who are relatively
slow in classical chess and in games with slightly
longer time controls but they can really speed up
right and lavon has proven that he is the type of
player he can be exceptional in bullet even if he
seems to be we call them time managers robert not
necessarily time takers like they just made they
manage whatever time is being given to them given
that particular time control right whether it's
classical grishik we know gets the most out of his
time right he gets under time pressure a lot five
minute and three minute but in bullet that doesn't
mean that they don't know how to manage their
clock there too by the way here comes a night
check and the eight pawns falling what's wait
but can i get trapped if you take it oh yeah take
it let's show it let's show it levon aronian just
offered a draw by the way yawn declined it but it
doesn't matter we're oh no yawn is going for the
win we're still going to show it if you had taken
the pawn king to c2 billy blue the knight runs out
of squares what's funny is black is probably
still not even losing if he trades but okay
back to the live game a king and pawn ending and
we will have peace throughout the land the uh
the two game lead maintain now right for lavon
robert and 25 minutes on the clock exactly
um not going to complain anymore danny
i used to complain that we had too many
berlins i think i've seen enough french's
for the day you've seen enough french's yeah
well notice that uh jan does acknowledge defeat
in this game at least the meaning he chose
about opening uh if you're just tuning in lavon
won a very nice game on the white side of this
four bishop d3 french just a game or two ago
and in that game it was c5 played by yon but not
here instead we have a different variation being
played we do black has the bad pawn structure but
the two bishops and you often hear the bishop pair
being advantaged i prefer having the superior pawn
structure in blitz games in particular i think
with less time on your clock it's just easier
to play positions with a sound a stable structure
and look at those pawns right if e takes d4 going
for a trade in comes the knight directly hitting
your c6 pawn and causing you some serious problems
yep interestingly that you said that in
faster time controls you just prefer having
the strategically easier position to play which
there are a lot of practical elements that go
into this kind of thing because sometimes it's
a position you're comfortable with that is most
effective not necessarily the objectively
best line um bishop a6 now played by yon and
levon's got to be thinking can
i get away with taking that pawn
that's also my question and yan of course going
for some tactical variations that include bishop
takes c3 as an idea because the knight on
e2 is pinned to this rook on f1 but after d
takes e5 the knight on f6 is also under attack
so there you go many different possibilities
i feel like you believe in lavon's position
here i do yeah i do and it's not just because
john played the french looks good i mean the
transition is based on like you wish if you
were black that you could take and the point is
the knight can't take because the rook is hanging
but i think there's just too many pieces
hanging for black right i mean tonight
i literally have calculated zero here robert
my style minimal work but my instincts tell me
and i tend to follow my heart white's better
listen to your heart or the eval bar either way
yeah no white is definitely doing
well here and you can tell that
in addition to how we're evaluating it look at
the time usage by young yeah he's saying all
the time ben plays knight to d5 and he's still
hoping to make use of this and frustrating pin
from a6 to f1 but to start with i think white can
play rookie one here as a move uh it definitely
deserves to be considered i would also look at i
don't want to play knight takes d5 that just fixes
your pawn structure so even a move like bishop d2
by the way i mean you you could i think rookie one
just makes the most sense just get the rook off
of the pin no okay levon's gonna trade now what
that was something that we
didn't like because because
now it's getting harder to defend the
night so what does lavon have in mind
i was thinking knight f4 but i
don't know how he works out so well
you're nothing if you're not tricky silly
robert that is c3 is interesting too because
even if you take the knight you played
rookie one and actually white is still
coming out up just a little bit ahead of
this is rook d2 or rookie one more precise
i actually don't know if it is but the point
is that once the bishop takes on c3 here
after b takes c3 that bishop on c1 wants
to go out to a3 and if that's the case
maybe having the option to double in
the d file is extremely valuable yes
he takes c3 bishop okay he takes there oh
okay so maybe it didn't matter in the end
yeah but it was an option you were right and that
was an interesting thing to cons i don't even
know if you were wrong i mean if the bishop came
there and somehow prevented castling it actually
had been a tricky little spot for the black king
okay so white's gonna have superior pawn structure
right so white's pawn structure will be better
but black has tremendous activity along the
d i think that it should offset the worst
pawn structure but in blitz and now lavon
being the one down on the clock i think that
jan has very good chances to hold this game
agreed tim population us that's the
only place i want to be right now
you're blushing over there i know i do love
a compliment uh so jan doing everything he
can to stop the mobility of white's
pawn structure i think that's smart
and oh i don't love that move so i liked what he
was restricting the pawns but in some positions
that king on f2 will snake to h3 and potentially
into g4 so i don't love pushing all the pawns uh
in this manner but i think that john has a
better grasp of this position than i do no
but you're you're not i mean that's a good point
looks like they're going to head for a draw anyway
um indeed they do but we'll bring up the analysis
board as they start their next game and take a
look at it because i think you were right in
the sense that um you know you highlighted
these pawns were advanced for one purpose which
was to restrict you're stopping f4 which would
support this pawn the h5 pawn is is stopping
any other advances by the pawns and as you said
kind of holding the king back of any potential
infiltrations this was an interesting decision
and risky if lavonne wanted more i wonder if
he couldn't have tried for a little bit more
um so i don't know i i kind of trust your
instincts i trust that spidey sense of robert hess
do you think if the match score uh was not what it
is right now that he would have played on i wonder
right which is that now we're already getting
into that meta you know meta strategy talk time
of the match right and the speeches championship
is unique and that you've got you know we always
call it the shot clock counting down so levon
actually has two advantages right now one on
the scoreboard the other on the time oh look i
did it i finally cured my weatherman dyslexia
i pointed to the clock correctly the first time
this feels so wrong but now i'm into it this is
why weathermen love their job you know i i have
to work on it because yeah it's for me i did it
for the first time i was gonna
dance alongside you there
let's do it ready like dancing with ourselves
i don't think that's exactly insane but but yeah
no seriously levon has you know the advantage of
the clock but but if he's doing that robert and
getting into bullet where you know a lot of people
feel like yawn could be the guy it's going to be
interesting by the way nepo back to the weirdness
back to b3 and lavon is matching him step for step
he said you're going to play some weird stuff i'm
going to push my a pawn and that is quite typical
if you fianchetto you often want to push your rook
pawn because you directly challenge that pawn and
open up your rook's line of vision down to harlem
night you just gifted a diamond membership to
maybe a friend of his that's a streamer go to
twitch.tv harlem night let's throw up that command
there so harlem night um but anyway yeah uh
thank you uh thank you there for gifting
giving the gift of chess education to a
friend way to go harlem night danny you're
getting so much love in the chat right now
do it really who'd you pay it wasn't me so
someone just said danny is so
positive he's forcing me to smile
yeah that's a big compliment the origins
over try to not smile while they're on
a jet ski while they're watching chess tv
try to not smile while you watch me do this
i mean it's pretty easy for me so
you're asking the wrong person chess tv
um we're back to the opening we had in game one
by the way this structure occurred and that bishop
was bad looks like the difference here is that
yawn has actually broken through on the queen side
let's go to the bat cave and see what the
difference was robert we had this exact opening
but here lavonne didn't have the advance of c5 and
knight c6 with d4 he played the a pawn first which
has led to kind of a very different position
right lavon goes for advancing a4 and now when
the structure opens up and black does get d4 he's
not able to keep it there because white has ways
to kind of wiggle out so i don't think this is as
good as the position lavon got in that first game
yeah it's not it's um more double edge i would say
because in that other game the position is very
closed and it remains closed to the very end of
the game here both sides have more chances which
is what you want if you're you're on the pumice
you want to win some games you're down two but
you're also creating some problems very concretely
your a4 pawn is isolated and can be targeted with
either adding more pressure along the a file or
bring your knight it's one of your knights to
attack that pawn right he commits away from that
idea you were pointing out knight b6 but you still
have what you're saying the a pawn here so you're
right i guess lavon um you know maybe doesn't have
the bind that he had in game one i was talking
about but it is more double-edged because a4 and
now a5 is is a bit of a target um but you know
we talked a lot about that in the first game
now c4 finally opening up the bishop on h7 yeah
that bishop actually looks very strong right now
and if you go knight to d3 you can capture it
which gets rid of the bishop but that knight is
trying to go to c5 and that looks kind of scary
he's going to put a knight on e5 no great bishop
but that's thematic right you give up that
pawn you eventually take on c6 you play good
night against bishop that isn't doing as much
as you would like or in fact in this case he's
just going straight for the b-pawn without
taking off that's why i liked my move bishop
b4 i mean i highlighted it not just because of
the apon robert but it was headed to c3 i think
bishop b4 was better than just taking the pawn
right away hey you're probably right this this
is fine right black is can't complain you okay i'm
just trying to liquidate now bad luck yeah it's a
an equal position that we're going to get and
i if you're yawn you're just deciding do i take
on d6 and then take on c6 or do i take on c6 and
just trade into an opposite color bishop position
i don't know you should rely
on you for those questions
i would take on d6 it feels
easier to rate c6 and win d4
yeah talking about shake jake bake bake bake
it right on d4 although black does get the
outside past pawn and we should make mention
that and black's king would be a bit safer
well yawn is taking some time that's something we
say every day he decides no he wants the opposite
code bishop ending uh it's interesting because
you know he is going to get the bishop on d5
protected by a pawn which is not something black
can get right i mean black could try to get the
bishop on c3 but it's not as effective as a bishop
on d5 poking here so i kind of like yon's choice
and wow he pushed the d-pawn so early i i was
going to mention that you put a bishop on c5
you can think about pushing
the pawn that felt too soon
yeah because he's going to go bishop c5 now and
make it harder for you to just win the d pawn
no oh that's a good move no he wants more and
actually white has to be careful here i'd say
yeah because if i get bishop b4 and d2 you're
in trouble yeah and that's a bailout move you're
right he just said yep i'm going to trade c4
for d3 robert's right because let's bring up
the analysis board because we're going to have a
draw now but that was a in fact we just had a draw
offer that's a really critical moment because
if you don't just bail out let's say you you
know what do you do like you try to there's no way
to blockade the pawn like bishop b4 is coming in
so yeah this was this was getting
tricky now we're gonna have a draw
yet well watch out two seconds gotta move
oh nine to two seconds okay no draw just yet
and the king on g7 feeling in worse shape than the
uh king on g2 k92 is very safe right now oh f7 0.5
he's losing f7 oh he's losing the game wow yawn
has made something out of nothing here and he oh
point one he literally made that move with point
one oh rookie sevens me if you see oh he finds it
the last time i was doing commentary with yon
and he had mate and one on the board he missed it
i don't know if you saw that it was the it was
one of the speeches grand prix there was a queen
g8 mate he missed it and went on to draw the
game actually wow against uh abusa tara if i
remember correctly yeah yeah danny i watch you
pay attention yeah i do i would you know me i've
always been a decent student oh man i thought
maybe you just watched the highlights on youtube
but i was going to follow that with except when
i'm watching you because i don't remember that
lecture you said that you taught me many years
ago hey we all everyone who's been watching us
for years now knows that you darned well remember
that lecture and you're just pretending so
no i really don't so yeah anyway you got it to
indian lad who won guess the move over there at
chess.com you can still play remember cash
prizes on the line if you're sitting on the
sidelines of twitch and youtube get better at
chess don't just watch it go play guess the move
um all right speaking of getting better at chess
pawn structure look at white's pawn structure only
one pawn island what's up pawn island you want to
see if there are pawns in uh the files adjacent
to one another right so white has pawns from the
b through the h file black has two pawn islands
the a and b pawns and then the d through h pawn so
white's position is structurally a bit more sound
and you also have taken towards the center because
black is left if the trait on b5 blacks off the b
pawn and white's uh kind of furthermost pawn is
the c3 pawn so i just want to talk about those
dynamics a little bit i personally prefer white's
position by quite a significant margin but danny i
feel like maybe i'm overestimating voice chances
but even if you're not though it's instructive
because i think especially well now the transition
has made it much more you know balanced right
because we have dynamic weaknesses for both
sides isolated c pawn and isolated b pawn as you
highlighted but what you were saying is totally
true and it sounds silly for us to go out of our
way to talk about pawn islands or groupings but at
this level that's exactly what they're looking for
is any sort of long-term weakness they can gang up
on um and create problems so positional weaknesses
five-head thing all right now white is um you
know pressing just a teeny bit right the c
pawn is objectively as weak as
the b pawn they're both isolated
but white's got a little more space the knight
is also tied down to the e pawn right this is a
little bit shaky here but we'll see if aronian
has a way to convert can you just take on e5
right away isn't it hanging you laugh at the
discovery of my bishop well the rook on b8 was
hanging at the end of that so oh scheizer wait
can i say that oh let's go let's go look at that
you're right oh bloody hell wait can i say that
too i feel like if you say curse words of other
languages in english you can get away with
it yeah the rook is hanging in the end blimey
oh danny why didn't he take you're right everybody
missed it besides robert hess no you said the
e the knight has to protect the epoch i know
but i was just talking i was talking generally
superficially i wouldn't even realize it was
actually hanging well that's why you know teamwork
makes the dream work i just got a note not not on
camera yet but i'll let you know yeah i just uh
i'm getting an fcc fine for that one so
for my my drop of multiple curse words in
other languages but you know what i do with
fines right a lot like my parking tickets
okay you're a good driver you don't that's true
but it was a it was a joke anyway h5 played um
lavon is pushing for a win for sure right that
was a that was a very alpha zero-ish movie
you honestly said movie and you've been talking
as if you're an awesome i know so queen of d5
is a good move you're inviting black to trade and
fix the structure and weaken the the e-pawn so jan
runs away instead yeah and these double h-pawns
they look weak but perhaps they're not as terrible
as i i thought because the h5 pawn can go to h4
where it's protected by the bishop don't take on
b7 do not do that yeah taking b7 would allow rook
b8 shaking big um and that's not that bad actually
you can actually sack the queen on b8 you're
saying yeah yeah that's funny that's funny
yeah you almost then you have the past c
pawn he almost could have gone for that
um but now yawn has the e4 pawn in
the queen sights along with the d-file
right oh that's a good move i like that move
a lot bishop yeah didn't expect it but i
am applauding it the main principle everybody
is you're just inviting white to fix your pawn
structure right undouble the h pawns
wait did it happened wow a queen f5
look at that that's like offering an
exchange into an ending where you have the
outermost past pawn and you have a bishop against
a knight so a really instructive moment here yeah
and yawn needs to think long
and hard because it's not about
seeing a tactical sequence here it's about
evaluating your chances to hold the game
if you do in fact take on f5 but i don't
see much of a choice because g5 is hanging
oh this is great for levon
goes for this opinion but
uh that's that's an instructive setup as well
yawn calculates it but he can everything comes
with tempo just in time so that he can get
the knight in kind of a nice spot where by
the way if it gets to d6 or h6 playing for
a win i mean i know the c pawn's strong but
c6 now i'm pushing that thing yeah the bishop
wow what an inconvenient little little i almost
said something about the bishop look at
what an inconvenient little you know what
blocking c1 making it super hard
for yon but he does trade it
and c4 yeah very good that's really
important moment because that king would have
snaked into d5 and into e6 that could have
been a problem although black does have this
h and g pawn which would have allowed him
to create a pass pawn but this should be
balanced right now rook c7 rook c8 can force a
draw and if levon wants it yeah i think we'll
see peace now and oh wait no yawn wants more he
says you're under time pressure lev let's dance
let's dance baby actually g4 checking team g5
i may have spoken too soon young can turn the
tables yeah rook c4 was such a key instructive
moment not only from a from a defensive standpoint
but as you highlighted now that the rook
has forced the king back black actually
robert watch out for crazy lines where i go here
and i sack my rook for the pawn but win anyway
that's very plausible so c7 king takes f5
i wasn't kidding and he wins on time oh
my gosh and he's as surprised as i was
not quite suffering from the same anxiety issues
i am but john john was definitely surprised there
and levon has his just head in his
hands and he's like what are you doing
we're definitely gonna get one more
game here in the three minute portion
the players have not started it yet but
they're deadlocked now they're tight back
in the heat of that game danny i forgot about the
match score i forgot about the clock situation
i was just looking at this very interesting and
curious ending here but i think you were right
that black actually turned the tables and yon
was bringing his king in and that's part of the
reason why levon lost some time it's actually it's
just good for black at this point yeah and i don't
know why the players aren't starting make sure
that uh they're aware that they should get going
um
yeah okay um the tide match so not
really advantage for either player as
far as stalling so for those who are like hey
someone's stalling i don't really know that it
makes a difference at this point in terms of the
total match clock ticking away above us but um
yeah i mean the final result was
because of the clock robber but
you got to give jan more credit than
that right i mean it actually was
you know had gotten away from lev on the board
and that idea of the rook coming down the night
maneuvering to f7h like he calculated that super
quickly it was super super smooth and paid off
yeah i mean we kind of are a bit harsh sometimes
on nepo for the way he plays too quickly in
moments where you're better than this
you don't need to make that mistake
uh we've seen it we saw that several times the
2019 sinkhole cup in the round one against vichy
right pretty sure he just blundered fully at the
end of the game in the last round against anish
kiri yan botched a rook end game where that he
probably should have held but in all seriousness
you know take that's the bad side of things the
good side of things is he does find these moments
where he's trying to press for a win he finds
instructive tech technical ideas very quickly so
gotta you know give jan the credit he deserves and
he's an amazing player and i really do think that
in this format he has a chance against anybody but
somehow in years past he hasn't been able to make
it to the final yep well this year as we know
he's on the magnus carlson side of the bracket
um you've got the hikaru nakamura kind of wesley
so side of the bracket on the other on the other
side of things and not to say that those four
guys are are necessarily the only favorites
but obviously those are the big names and um or
the people that have made it the furthest in the
last couple of years particularly with nakamura
so um anyway yeah i'm with you 100 and i think
that sometimes the blessing is also a curse right
you highlighted where yon has frankly blown games
and given away points because he played too fast
but he's also sometimes just super impressive like
here he's already up a minute on the clock
and in blitz that's usually an advantage um
blood pressure is this we had the same
reaction but it was like it was like what
are you doing lavon like that's just not a you
know anyway apparently it's all good everyone
all good in the hood make a trade wait queen
f6 queens is a really good move hitting f3 and
hitting b2 oh we found it yeah it forces
the trade and the knight comes to e5 and
taking e5 would be lights out everybody that is
a bad idea don't do it and it's a good lesson
in when pieces are attacking one another yeah you
one side does capturing first help me or should
i provoke my opponent to take my piece that's
what lavon has just said please take building
the tension baby just building the tension
baby and those double pawns danny is blitz
not enjoying those things well you highlighted it
let's go to the analysis board because you made
a point a few times right that the instructive
part of yes objectively maybe this is okay for
white classical chess the g file's as useful
as the double pawns but in fast time controls
so hard to take on a strategic weakness and
then not make a mistake you're a human being
and now lavon has just won a pawn and might
be pressing for more for the rest of the game
yeah he is an option here you can
trade queens i would not do that
when my opponent's king is still quite weak
but he can take on d1 and play a better ending
i think he needs to move more quickly
in positions like this he plays queen f6
he spent 14 seconds that's not that much time
all things considered but we have seen him get
down to the waning seconds and that's where
he blunders or gets outplayed you're right and
just like we've given fair criticism to yon
for playing too fast at times in his career
um i think that if we're talking about you know
the matches today there's been a couple games that
lavon lost because of time pressure right whether
he actually lost on time or made a blunder so
i think it's fair um he needs to speed up just
a little bit he's not losing this game he's not
losing this game i'm looking at the position here
comes that rook to h6 h6 i mean you could take on
b2 put your knight on e5 and try to get your
knight to the f3 square you can play no he's
building the tension i like it he's he's uh doing
what you said right bring pieces continue to stare
down the trade because the trade only activates
your pieces further i love it oh man just every
piece of his is doing something useful and look at
look at white's rooks in particular the rook on b1
it's a purely passive defensive piece and h i
mean levon is playing a model game right now
yeah something we learned very early on as
chess players is you never want your big pieces
defending your little pieces bad sign and now
even queen e4 you're already up one pawn head
to the end game where e3 is weak you could you
could just do that and that's why he took on g3
the h1 was pinned so an instructive lesson by
lavon in pawn structure creating an isolated
pawn for his opponent and the light squares we
talk about the dynamic knight against a bishop
if that knight gets to e4 there's nothing
that white can do about it oh feels so good
the e4 squared just love it all right how
do you get to it nobody's just taking pawns
greedy man yep
i know you're never supposed to play it but i do
recommend f6 here oh yeah f6 there would have been
also possible but he goes for checkmate instead
the h5 pawn was hanging so i guess he can uh
uh he actually couldn't have captured
so everything looks good at this point
and he's ahead on the clock so the time's
up by the way is the last three mini game
yeah officially regardless of the result
we will be in bullet after this game
and will it be a one game lead for aronian or
or are we shocked by a blunder we'll find out
but yeah yawn came back he was he
was down by two in the match and
but yeah look at look at this this
is great technique i love rook g4
but i said this is a model game like i understand
that jan didn't play the opening very well he made
a mistake but it feels like every single
move that lavon has played has had purpose
and he's just gonna win this game and take a
lead into the bullet i think john maybe played
that for the shot of some tactic with the bishop
and brooke but he maybe forgot about d1 check so
either way he's still in big trouble um
lavon not allowing any kind of counter play
you have to find some other way to
defend the g pawn i think f6 is in d4
what d4 was also good because of
the d4 was also good e1 square
oh gosh now you get stop
even knight g4 so you can threaten rookie
one oh or the battery or the battery
yeah make it stop all the
light squares knight f3 check
take on e1 how many extra pounds
do you have the answer is enough
even nice g1 if you have a king d1 queen
h1 check and here's knight takes b3
he's gonna gobble the g pawn unless yon
throws in the towel which he does so
on that note wow we predicted a close match
everybody there's a reason the smarter chess
prediction had this as close to a 50 50 toss-up
as we ever get and robert i mean are you excited
for the bullet here i don't want to go to break
because i just want to talk about this with you
well before we do go to break danny i just don't
know which lavonna ronin we'll see we'll see if
the player who is a little bit too deliberate
for his own good where we see the yon napaneshi
who comes out blazing with sharp lines i have no
idea so danny you excited we see danny wrench win
his second primetime smackdown taking on john
bartholomew if you haven't subscribed with your
twitch prime now officially a you problem
you can also do a regular subscription uh
no but we do really appreciate the support
to you and all of our premium members thanks
thanks for it you make this happen enjoy the
prime time smackdown at the break the rest
of you enjoy a commercial about a video game that
i'm never going to buy my kids we'll be right back
all right here we go hey i'm not going to be
ashamed of a sweep because i've already been
swept twice in these matches you shouldn't be
all right let's go okay okay i'm gonna i'm gonna
go for your tory oh wait no you switched
to the london switching it up classic sean
anyway yeah it's i feel like i've been here before
so yeah this strangely looks like the first game
yeah oh darn it that was a that was a not
good approach by me um okay that's painful
yep pain pain
okay you're giving me that i'm gonna
take the foursquare got two okay
yes take that square if possible
all right i guess a draw doesn't get me to
win you know obscure bishops that all drawn
but technically you still have room to come back
in a draw scenario not that that's gonna happen
okay okay i'll take the d file uh-oh
you're playing very fast okay you've woken
up this is scary i evidently missed my coffee
today john has woken up and i have to
be careful of my clock again no okay
try to gather that little pawn there
let my queen into d2 let her in
oh
this did not go well free move town population
dan i trapped that night yet oh crap
okay all right okay i clearly poked the bear
all right don't be but you're wearing that grizzly
adam shirt where are you going right after this
this is a branding thing at this point like this
is like you're going hunting for dance exactly
okay forgot to take the wrapper off this show
is not brought to you by nestle pure life
although it is my preferred brand of bottled water
okay okay this is it i i've you've got game five
written all over your face and i'll give you a
chance at the scandi to get there let's do it
if i win i want it to be in your home turf
oh but not this line i hate this line oh mine
i thought you would like this one oh this
is so irritating this can be fun okay okay
uh i don't know what i'm saying i give you credit
because usually you avoid this candy against me
i do and so you know this is a it's uh playing
with some guts dan yep um gotta respect that gotta
respect that um what are we doing here i guess
i'm gonna do this all right i'm gonna no i don't
want to give you that i like the dark squares
okay what i'd like to do here don't even know
yeah there we go this is some intense uh
positional maneuvering yeah no i've been uh
learning from a positional
master her name's beth harmon
ah i've heard of her i forgot my knight was pinned
that was adorable of me i tried to play knight c5
um what are you doing here that
was probably a bad move by me
what am i doing oh no oh no this is the money
i'm using this is the danny we know and love
okay okay what happened there i'm gonna
let my time run out that was going well
for me i should have played a3 i guess on b5 i
should have slowed down your little your little
minority yeah that probably would have been a
better idea i agree you're so smooth sometimes
so
and yet again we have a
snapshot of our top guessers
playing against the move dragon b70 this was
the last game of the three minute portion so
a couple of random games chosen still dragon b70
sitting there at the top robert as he usually does
but we'll see when when it's all said and
done who ends up taking on the cash prizes
just like we'll see when it's all said and
done just how accurate these smarter chess
predictions were if uh if they are guess
what we have robert we have overtime chess
that's true because yonder palm she predicted to
be a one game favorite in the bullet portion levon
aronian thanks to this final victory in the 3-1
segment has the lead what do you think danny is
it going to be accurate all jokes about smarter
chess aside i honestly i would love overtime
chess you know you know how i feel you know um
anything that keeps me away from anything that
keeps me away from you is a bad thing i want this
show to last forever uh forever is a long time
and i think you'll eat those words but i mean
i'm with you i think that you know especially
you just gave us one of those moments where
someone says i love you and the other person goes
hey i started off i just said i love
you and you didn't say i love you back
i started off the show with like an endearing
statement and you kind of brush it aside so
that was you getting back at me no two
wrongs don't make a right okay two wrongs
don't make it right just ask beyonce all
right it's time for the bullet to begin
yeah better start otherwise i'm
leaving all right here we go
hey we have a sicilian again yeah back
to that allopin yes and lavon quick in
the opening stage of the game going for this b4
line not so fast that's why a5 was played whoa
yeah i wonder if jan took a peek at this at
all but he def definitely has a little bit
of a better start than he did previously here
comes the busted open center that should favor
the bishop on g7 if we talk about specific pieces
because that wants the diagonal to open up but
maybe not so fast knight c6 knight e4 both sides
have weak pawns that they have to figure out here
indeed d4 b2 versus c6 and maybe a5 um yellen
offers a trade straight up of c for b and now
queen d2 i would play just to protect b2 give my
rook access to d once what he says i'm taking c6
i'm with you i felt like lavon should have sat a
little bit on that but he goes for some activity
instead well i think that black's pawn structure
is stuck in place or the e4 pawn in particular
whereas that d-pawn may quickly rush itself
to d6 in which case not only is the f7 square
problem because the bishop on c4 is so strong but
there's a past pawn that you have to deal with
and okay d5 very tempting here
there's bishop d5 huh going around for the pawn so
danny i mean i like white's position i think he's
doing everything you could ask for in a bullet
game and a5 is weak so queen a4 was played yeah
i agree he's also playing quickly yawn's supposed
to be the faster player but not so fast as aronian
and the rook can drop like the c1 that's
important yeah the queen comes back
or the rook they're both possible
uh and rook c1 is queen d3 check that's why he
drops the queen back queen d3 still happens and
down goes a3 gives up the a pawn but he's still a
little bit better as long as the king doesn't get
in trouble look at look at that move g4 love it i
was looking at bishop f7 check and queen c4 but i
think that there's bishop king f7 bishop e6 within
his book c7 check no that works oh he goes for it
yeah if if rook takes the bishop
hangs everybody if king takes queen c4
bishop c4 thank you you're to thank everything
that you don't lose your game there thank god
for that bishop c4 and now white's just up and
pawn king g2 play h3 even if the rook comes to
three you fly queen c2 yep he's doing it playing
all the moves as i highlight him and here comes
rook c7 i guess and yeah black can't move well
i can't move you can bring the queen to c6 here
comes the d-pawn at long-last bishop d4 anybody
yep oh bishop d4 there's no way you sell this you
can trade everything and e4 falls in the end he
takes takes yep everything and white's gonna be up
there goes that passer queen c3
check wins the check picks it up
and then there's rook f727 just
to uh end the game that's a check
i was like wait what's that
always check it might be mate
and there you go levon aronian takes the
first bullet game and we are going to have
a photo finish here i mean if yawn does prove to
be the better bullet player he's going to have to
he's gonna have to do it uphill right now down
two games with 26 minutes left in the total clock
can you say tiebreaker can you say overtime
i can't say overtime i'm just not sure we're
going to get it but danny what's interesting about
this is you and i and smarter chess predictions
all thought that hey jan is the better bull player
between these two but that increment really helps
of course and look at lavon's rating i might
add yep wait but we saw the rating okay the
ratings studied sorry john studied this position
because we had this as a possibility in like the
like first or third or whatever game
of the match and he just changed the
move order and gave up his dark square
bishop so jan studied this at some point
so he improved on his earlier game
although i like yon's position better
right so that's something john improved on his uh
or your game from this match oh i thought you were
saying lavonne you lavon stuff i just missed who
you studied yeah yeah yeah i was gonna say i love
white's position now so uh he he definitely looked
at this during one without remember this this is
the second bullet game i'll try to remember
to ask that question i mean now knight c7 is
crushing oh rookie 58. boomtown it's over look
at john he's uh he's a happy camper over there
this is a for making it tricky he's still still
busted and if you okay like bishop takes c6 even
it just destroyed the pawns oh yeah you could
you could probably enter an end game with
knight against bishop at some point as well yeah
other bishop c6 oh rook d6 is bishop f7 oh gosh
wow you weren't wrong though i wonder if you
could have just traded on c6 taking d8 gone
to the end game and the knight was winning
over the bishop but don didn't go for it
well he might go over the check now yeah rookie
eight at the end yeah rookie it now too rookie
eight takes quincy said he takes takes and then
then you win up six at the night look at those
dancing heads by the way that tells you we've had
a back and forth match and uh that the underdog
by a very very small percentage 46 to 54
percent i think lavonne is back on top
now you take c6 and win the king of pawn no you
just take f7 oh i'm not sure i love this um and
the reason why is you look where the extra pawn
is it's on the king's side h8 square dark square
it's not easy to make progress here yeah plus
black is already in a great position blockading
with a centralized knight holding all the squares
yeah b6 put all your oh he's gonna b4 okay yeah he
wants b4 but the king is coming to e4 96 that says
not so fast d6 holds the square push it baby no
yeah i feel like jan should have
had more yeah john should have
john was winning i mean at one point here for sure
and how to do this a b4 so knight f593 here comes
wait a second oh this is no good john just took a
peek over at the clock i'm sure but that was what
his uh his eyes were there and his face is like
not happy i mean the thing is is is the knight
okay he's giving up c2 to go king d5 and win c5
yeah but he's better now right you have to move
f5 okay this is so tough made it with 1.9 seconds
now this is winning for white right wow
six one point one second you gotta move
oh point two literally living on the
increment point one yeah this is crazy
bishop four traps the knight the knight
gets trapped oh my gosh then i can go to ccp
no because you got the c2 square yeah oh
but that's why he reordered the bishop
now he's pushing the a pawn but now
you can play tickle 91 knight back
okay king b7 a6 a7 this is just
nuts wait king might get trapped now
all right so knight so crazy yeah because the
knight forces bishop b5 guard to the g6 square
he's ready to get out he gets out king b5 and
he's going to win yeah now he's winning for sure
oh my god somehow lost whatever the thread
was that the knight had over the bishop and
now yawn should be able to convert this yeah
the knight can't stay there forever yeah down
goes somebody's trap pony and with it oh man
well from a match strategy point of view um
you know every game that lasts a long time i
guess is still a favor you know a good game
for lavon but you know this is close enough
that you can't even really say that right at
this point neither side is really thinking
about the clock it's a one game match with
20 minutes to play that was not the cleanest
victory for john robert but he did get it done
he did you know when it his back was against the
wall and he could not really he can't afford to
not win games because there's still plenty of time
left 21 minutes but he really needed that for his
confidence if nothing else we have another
interesting position where black has these
pawns in the fifth rank are they strengths because
you can keep pushing the four they're restricting
white's pieces are they weaknesses because after
bishop f1 knight c4 type of moves those pawns
can quickly get under attack yeah notice how i
highlighted them green when you said strengths
and then i switched to red when you said weakness
um you know you are as long as you know that
i'm also contributing to the show that was all
you're you're the best commentator in your dream
thank you i love you you just uh no but i will
highlight for your ideas anytime baby you can
be my wingman i'll be yours um all right e5 is
a target you're right and queen to b3 might make
it trickier for black because i'm gonna bet on
these pawns becoming not strengths but weaknesses
you know when when you said you can be i thought
were gonna say you can be my bodyguard i could be
your long-lost pal but i'll be your chest coast
toaster no no different song that's okay yeah
all right by the way they did prove to
be weaknesses lavon picked them apart
and uh what's something you got a couple miners
for the rook but i like white with the open king
uh yeah i agree oh okay so what's what
is the actual count it's two minus miners
for a rookie pond three pawns three points yeah
so rookie one knight e5 can come next i would
probably advise to trade some pieces oh but
c4 is hanging oh it does anyway so queen c4
looks possible he decides to go watch out for
those light squares danny right that could be
a quick counter it'll get baited
that's that's great advice
so queen a7 is happening next that's
such an important pawn to lose
yeah the outside passer could win the game
in the end rook d1 maybe then h a4 a5 then
just push that black is like a stuck i
mean you're pinned down to d7 so we're
by the way he was just inviting bishop e5
which would have been a blunder rook d7
nice now pushing did win the c pawn which
gives him bishop d4 as a possibility
okay so he's gonna pull the heat and then can
he take on h6 can you just go for that pawn
wait he's really gonna take a draw and jan says
no dawn says no i'm surprised by that i'm sh now
now the bishops are dominant queen of four lavon
is getting nervous under time pressure that was
the first time said that all day where lavon
just i mean that was like clearly a dubious
approach there and he was better but didn't didn't
uh he was nervous about his clock and now he's now
he's gonna lose the end game we're gonna have
a tight match he's in such big trouble because
of the presence of the sea pawns if those pawns
are on the board actually he's getting the pawn
okay now now you can find a way to get
this pawn he got it and that makes it
easier because look at the h6 pawn look at the
color corner you need to give up that rook for
the light square bishop so once you take the
pawn on c5 bring your king all the way back
towards the h file and you can give up your rook
all you gotta do is zack this guy for this guy
yeah or you can try to win this game maybe
that c pawn is gonna win him the game
stranger things have happened okay rook c3
no he doesn't put the rook behind the pawn
wait this is actually getting really worrisome
for young yeah this is the bishops are supposed
to be better than the brook here but i have no
idea what's going on oh my gosh i think he's in
big trouble i think he's losing this game rook g8
and then c7 d7 thank you and the f pawn pushes f4
wow what a turnaround wow
so much for me calling the tide match joshua
chamberlain lives i jinxed it i forgot about
you remember that guy who hated me whatever
happened to joshua i bet joshua chamberlain
exists in the chat just under a different name if
you're out there joshua chamberlain show yourself
we're gonna see king g3 h2 for oh he's so sick h2
you bring the rook over he's going to get a knight
no he's made it oh i thought but even
even if he gets tonight he's still losing
yes well we'll bring up the analysis board real
quick i missed it the timing but that's still an
instructive tactic because white is winning in
these end games everybody even if you're down
a tempo like if if black was to move here the
queen gets mated the black's only move is to
get a knight and then you play king f3 and it's
still a winning end game for white because uh
the the king and knight gets separated and it's
a force win so anyway lavon wins it's a two-game
lead joshua chamberlain strikes back that's what i
keep thinking about how many people here remember
joshua's chamber if you're out there you actually
know the inside joke i mean i just go up even more
y'all but you didn't finish the early days of of
of of chess success on twitch somebody didn't like
me that i ever said anything apparently and
if i ever said like oh this guy's gonna win
he really was like belaboring the point so we had
to mute him in banana and we kicked him wherever
you're out there joshua chamberlain turns out you
were right joshua chamberlain i do jinx players
so this position is very good for yon
because look at his the place from his pieces
he has the d5 square under his control look
at the night seat on c6 dominated by a pawn
three squares away and that's very important
you want to look at how your pieces can start
uh going forward and getting aggressive and
that's exactly what jan's doing pushing his
pawns at the king side taking over central
squares and levon's actually not doing so
poorly to reroute his pieces knight to e6 give
me the f4 square but white is clearly ahead ooh
nice oh wait apparently it's not a good tactic
it looks good to me wait is the queen getting
trapped or g takes the knight of four the queen
gets trapped in f6 whoa whoa whoa i know kung fu
wait actually where's that queen
going yeah how's he getting out
it's knight f5 knight f5 holds oh he didn't
no knife is rook a6 oh wow the queen's getting
trapped in more ways than one that's no fun um
so bishop g7 queen h4 the queen gets to
escape bishop e7 queen takes e5 the queen
escapes for now well this is a crazy wild
position lavon has no time to figure it out
no he really does but if we see the eval
bar we know there's some way for black to
do this but with no time there's just i i'm
gonna guess yan gets away with stealing every
single pawn the queen just did and lives to
tell about it wow i mean queen c4 only move
you could go to b6 but then there's like 92 and
right knight takes c3 happens there oh well now
there's 92 tanks and g4 is hanging whoa oh he's
going for the attack right away and watch out
for rook takes e3 ideas with queen g4 to follow
oh yeah okay this is getting very tense spicy
rook 63 no jason g4 yeah rookie three he had
it he made my voice go high nobody does that
nobody makes me bleed my own blood he still has
so much pressure though the 93 is stuck here
seriously black still black still has a ton of
pressure but with no time on the clock i'm going
to guess that he missed his chance with brook
takes e3 what's the material count blackstone pawn
one yeah yeah and now you have queen e6 at the end
of some lines if you want raid here comes queen e6
okay i mean you go to the end
game if you're into it but no
buy once more so what's we need eight and
then rook g3 no richie's already wouldn't work
was that king upon ending winning i don't know
he misses me oh my god my name is queen takes g3
oh my god multiple wins missed only takes f2
as me wait what is happening here who's gonna
win queen d5 check and it's in blacks
winning levon is up a pawn oh my god
what just happened oh jeez louise what did
louise ever do to you danny i know right pushing
my blood pressure up now it's definitely
now lebron is somehow winning this game
oh my god they've got time too it's like
somebody needs to remind them slow down boys
you've got some time on the old tickety
rook c4 end the game i can't my voice
okay black is still gonna win and this
is this could be a back breaker for
yon oh my gosh he's shaking his
head because that was one that
oh that's one that's going to make the uh
end of the month twitch clip highlights real
to the analysis board we go let's just at least
show that there was a mate for those of you who
didn't exactly catch why we were freaking out
because right here queen to d3 was checkmate
and then queen takes g3 was winning
and at some point i think yawn was almost winning
again oh my god all right back to the next game
oh man wowser was fun hey i i didn't know
how much i missed it until now that i'm here
i realized just the adrenaline rush so much fun
watching these games come down to the last moment
this is there's a lot on the line here these
are thousands of dollars uh on the line in these
chess games and uh this game's over john's getting
crushed look at him he's just john's falling apart
falling apart at the tilt the tilt is to
resign and then just win the next game
i know that's asking a lot but he has over
10 minutes left that is yeah my problem is
he could lose another two full minutes
on the clock and lose this game anyway
right so from a match strat pov is the k i'm
gonna try to speak how the kids would say
i am matt strat pov af as af sometimes people say
as af which doesn't make any sense by the way yeah
yeah you're you're as a fool i get it but please
don't that's what it means right as a fool oh my
gosh i i was just saying how much i was enjoying
it now i really like all right yeah this is tough
lavon needs to uh i mean john needs to throw in
the towel here this is going to be yes chances
are the hole i feel like no no i should resign but
it's too late right now it's too late to go back
too late to apologize yeah well that was
that's been true for a long time now wow
i have nothing to say anymore i
don't have anything to say either
but thank you to mary 1918 who
just gifted a membership to someone
you gave the gift of chess education there's
a lot of people doing that around the holidays
that was well done nice all right no but
seriously i think this is almost i i did
not think we were going to be in a position
to call the match at all in this in this
match and it's still there's plenty of time
but we are now under 10 minutes and yawn is
really i mean it was it was a three-game swing
that last game i mean it was it was insane
uh but lavon is seven seconds so you
know okay there you go yeah now quite
yet although i'm with you i'm with you
84 all right rook f3 let's go let's go
the problem is he's down two full pawns
okay you're down two pawns here comes queen
d5 force the ladies off the board might be
the smartest thing levon ever did making
john think he has chances to win this game
because it's it's look at that
look at that clock oh wait
okay but there might be that kane knife six
check comes ouch knight f6 chick is rover
over billy blue resign resign
yawn while you still can
and 97 yeah i'm it's every game from here
on out must be one every game must be one
and pretty quickly at that because
you have just under eight minutes
and even if there were no increment
that's two minutes per game this
you gotta get this one yawn and you gotta look
i'm sure you're going to whatever and dan the
dyslexic weatherman i messed it up this
time yeah you gotta you gotta go that way
i had it right you gotta poke it up um yeah this
is uh this is i think we've gone full tilt and
and i think that uh lavon
has survived the storm i mean
already looking like a good position for black
again up a clean pawn yeah you know white would
like to unleash some sort of attack but that
bishop on c8 may just land on g6 and say what next
so silent between us right now what do you say
it's so silent between us right now i just don't
i just don't know what to say our relationship
is is beyond words the smile on your face robert
lets me know that you need me oh my gosh there's
a look in your eyes are you telling me that i
say it best when i say nothing at all right
you and i could talk or not talk for hours
boo oh we need to check oh gosh if the knight
moves you take with check so there's no mates
no attacks and this is an owie
an owie for yon and with him
i think uh i think an owie and his
speech has championship chances
yeah this is uh it's already we go up by
five games with only five minutes left we
can officially call it so either a blunder
heard round the world or we're looking at a
surprising result i guess i mean for lavonna
rhonian i mean not i mean we said this was 50
50 and i and i said i had no idea was going to
win this match and voted our stats but i guess
i thought it would be close all the way down
to the finish and this is this is surprising
can i just make a quick comment
danny do you mind of course
so uh smarter chess remember what you said
about the bullet portion of this match
do you remember that let me go to chat and back
up my boy robert yeah that what's martyr jess
was it like plus two for yon and bullet
according to smart chess predictions
so just throwing that out there yeah
well lavonne doesn't play enough
oh okay she's broken she wants me that was a sound
effect if only our eval bar had sound effects
you so clear i just discovered a new trick
every time i pull my ear i go whoa look at that
and we still haven't exactly wait we we still
possibly have a match if young wins the next too
quickly yawn has got to win every game from
here on out but he's still down by three as
pretty as that was levon would have to lose and
lose quickly right and that was smarter chess
pulling some strings behind the scenes after
i started talking some smack he doesn't want
it to look so bad on his stat sheet yeah that
was i don't know how that happened but anyway
lavon right now still with a three-game
lead but he's spending quite a bit of time
jan's getting what he needs he he needs to win and
he's a win fast and the first step is playing fast
one game at a time and i
guess you know not that it
not that's the most critical thing on their mind
but every win right now is still worth cash right
with the format of the event so keep keep winning
games john you never know just keep swimming
finding nippo just keep swimming just keep
swimming um oh oh negative two would be made
but because i play king of seven knight f2 is is a
main on the board that's a threat it is and bishop
g3 in some version could be a threat too or pawn
g3 pawn g3 right now g3 g3 go for f2 open up g4 ah
oh but there's f3 i guess i was trying to break
this position open yeah g3 is a real threat though
and look at levon down to 10 seconds he's using
his time wisely because every second off the
match clock gets him closer to a match victory
but we're still in striking distance here knight
pawn g3 we got mate on the next move oh the bishop
goes back to g1 so it's not me oh he gets out
but h4 h3 has to be something yeah also the
bishop coming in h3 wait i just got out of this
oh my gosh and he's wasting precious seconds at
the very least even if he lavon loses his game the
time that's getting off the clock is so important
even if he loses he defended perfectly to uh
take more time off the clock
by the way look at john's time
he needs he needs to win this actually he's if
he doesn't win now they're not gonna have enough
time remaining yep anyone okay lavon loses on
time takes more precious seconds off the clock
i mean this is a bit like jim carrey talking
to mary swanson dumb and dumber you're saying
there's a chance right saying there's a chance
i think you need new jim carrey references
have i used that one more than enough
yeah yeah we gotta retire that one
don't be sad don't be sad i'm sorry okay by the
way yawn is a scotch expert and doesn't play it
often against his uh his elite super grand master
peers these days but it is it is something he
knows well only a minute 39 on the clock i mean
it is possible all they have to do is start the
last game so yawn has to win this game and
then start the last game before time is up
right and that's why yon is moving so quickly
which can backfire over the board but he needs to
do this he has no other choice and well he's going
to bishop f5 next and it could be a bit scary for
that king but for now there are plenty of black
pieces there are not enough white attackers
oh my gosh you're really looking at that
time a minute oh a minute ticking down
lavon lavon's just gonna win the match on
the clock all he has to do is get himself
in a position where he can let the time tick down
yon dug himself too big of a hole it looks like
um look at this hg5ht5 please open up the h file i
want to meet you in the next 30 seconds he's using
his time letting it tick down 15 seconds i wonder
how up to date they are though right because
uh the players do they know exactly the amount
of seconds remaining they share the same global
clock but isn't even the production clock they
have the official clock on whatever on their
they have it we share it with them i don't know
how closely they keep it in front of them but um
i think officially at this point unless there's a
win on the board for white in the next 10 seconds
we have a victor in the match and that's going to
be lavon ironian yeah it looks like he's winning
over the board as well he's up a full piece bishop
to h6 closes the h file it looks like lavon has
made it through that's it just like that speed
chess championship round of 16 drama continues
here lavon ironian defeats yon dupont machine
regardless of the result of the final game it goes
lavon's way as is poetic it would seem and robert
levon aronian pulls off the upset albeit a very
very close match this was the eight nine matchup
in the bracket so really hard to call it an upset
it was it was predicted as a borderline
coin flip and levonaroni and gets it done
yeah it was predicted 56 in yan's favor and that
came down to the bullet but because levon had the
lead going into the bullet and was playing really
well in the opening games young could never quite
find a in road to take the match control away
from lavon ronin congratulations to the armenian
number one he played an excellent match yeah wow
incredible stuff he gets to face his friend in the
next round in maxine vashey the grab but we will
be back with final moments we leave you with the
final moments of my best of five match that went
down between john bartholomew and i for those
subscribers to the twitch channel and all of our
supporters we really appreciate it here's our
game five of primetime smackdown and when we
return final moments of today's scc battle
all right hey you didn't get all dressed
up for nothing you're welcome for having a
game five i i liked the shirt but now thank
you it's only fitting we haven't we haven't
played for a while so yeah i think the people
want us i think the people are happier this
way what happens in the event of a draw we play
again um let's just do that and split the money
what do you think that's fine by me you're like
you know whatever i don't even know what's going
on here all right here we go um i sent you a
rematch here we go you're gonna go for your
silly you're going to do it you're doing your okay
i'm going to play boring chess i got to mix it up
i almost played the blumenfeld and then
decided decided no okay really okay okay
okay oh my god this is just
terrible terrible all right
oh i'm so bad it always happens this way this
goes fast too bestified bullet i'm like the face
of someone who choked in life that's what i am
this is kind of like your adopted danny matches
but a little bit different i mean yeah like i
saw that draw you got against a niche geary i
think it was it felt really good actually to get
that draw and you're done it feels even better
that i know that you watch yeah for sure all right
well congratulations thank you whatever moving on
now you've deadlocked things and your pawns are
also very weak i agree king d7 and he missed it
oh and i don't know what john said but it wasn't
pg oh man and again he's just shaking his head
oh wow that was painful
and we are back here with the final moments of
today's speeches championship match lavon aronian
takes down john dupont michie if you couldn't
tell from that moment of the match today we will
actually not have interviews with either player
today uh and robin and i will give you our final
thoughts and preview the upcoming matches here
in uh here for the next next 5-10 minutes or so
on that note robert so again this was uh not
not a surprising victory in any way the stats
said it was going to be close but i think the way
it ended definitely surprised some of it was that
one critical bullet game right that john lost
that was the backbreaker yeah truthfully it did
feel like lavon had the upper hand i would say the
majority of the time in this match of course jan
had some games where he played really excellent
chess i i think the winner was the player who did
play better throughout i think that jan was
probably going to be upset with himself it's
how the bullet went you're absolutely right danny
he should have had a chance there he was only down
one game from remember correctly heading into the
bullet and yet lavonne was the player who seems
stronger of the two so i don't know if you agree
with me but i do believe that jan will be upset
but lavon is the deserted victor in the match i
agree i mean from start to finish uh he also he
also was leading most of the match start to finish
right after jumping out to a two and a half one
and a half lead he maintained that lead all the
way until yon tied it at eight eight before the
last game of the three minute portion so you know
usually the person who's leading throughout was
also i mean sometimes they lead and and it never
gets tied again right but but it definitely a sign
that lavon felt in control of the match um and uh
in the bullet he surprised the smarter chess stats
right along with maybe people who thought nepo
would be the the faster player in the 1-1 segment
and he takes the match victory shout out again to
all of our subscribers and our gifted memberships
coming in here over the last few moments we
hope you hope you enjoyed the match and we do
appreciate your support speaking of other matches
we've got one coming up tomorrow for the first
time this year we have a back-to-back affair ikara
nakamura the number one seed the man at the top
takes on hike marty rosian obviously we know
that hayek is super talented super talented
young player also from armenia lavon aronian's
countrymen the victor of today certainly there's
not much to say other than hikora nakamura
is the number one seed for a reason robert
and a heavy favorite but your quick thoughts on
the things you're looking forward to tomorrow
yeah i think that hikaru is in everybody's mind
the from pretty much the winner before the match
even begins i don't think that hikaru necessarily
feels that way he has great respect for hike
marching roasting who's a phenomenal player but
he's not there yet he's not quite at the tippy top
the upper echelon the elite level that is required
to face off against a car in such a long match
but hype will outplay icaru in segments he will
have some better games but ultimately yeah hikaru
is almost certainly going to win that match
yep it would be it would be the shocker heard
around the world right uh for sure but we'll
see what hike can put up as far as as far as
uh the fight goes and i'm sure we'll have a lot of
interesting moments regardless uh we also have one
more match-up after that i'm sorry no two we have
november 15th and november 16th a circle on your
calendar duda versus caruana and artemia versus
geary uh you know i think we could argue that
after the nakamura mardi rossium match both those
other matches are our total coin flips robert they
certainly are young christoph duda the stronger of
the two players you know between himself and five
minute quran in the online sphere but fabinho
caruana is the number two player in the world
he took magnus carlsen to the tie breaks of the
2018 world chess championship and on the other
side of the bracket artemyev the speed demon we've
seen him beat hikaru in speed chess championship
grand prix and title tuesdays we know how strong
he is fully capable of taking out anish giri
who is the lower seed so giri despite having a
higher classical rating and being one of the more
talkative players of the bunch he has his work
cut out for him and you know that magnus would
he would enjoy beating a niche in a head-to-head
matchup we see the chat saying they'd love to have
an anish versus magnus quarterfinals i think a lot
of people would i mean magnus carlson interviewed
after his match victory over parham monk sulu said
he thought that art or tamiya was the favorite and
anish had some fun trolling and going back and
forth about that i don't i don't think magnus
even meant it as a slight or even being sarcastic
i think he does see artemium as the favorite in
a blitz match even if anish geary is the stronger
classical player but either way i do think it's a
7-10 seed for a reason meaning it's it's pretty
close to a coin flip um and uh in increment
time controls which you rarely see when these
guys are just playing casual blitz and bullet
you know a lot of times a stronger player
does win out so we'll see what a niche can do
um and then as you already said duda and caruana
i i don't that to me feels as much a toss-up as
the one we had today i have no idea who's
going to win that one fabiano's working on
his blitz all the time um and jan christoph
duda is still the higher seed for a reason
all right we also had a lot of people
playing guess the move and in the end
random game chosen gives and rewards indian
lad look at that grand master indian lad
taking home the cash prize shocking dragon
b70 i guess um but uh we know that he he
makes a regular habit of taking taking home cash
every sec match so congratulations to indian lad
as well as our two basic level membership members
who upgraded themselves to premium by playing
guess the move today nick moyes and cn riddle
buying riddle is that like super cyan i don't
think so you know you know what it feels like
dragon b70 was taking a food break like went to
make himself a sandwich and then that was the game
chosen and that was the game shows all the time
because the fact that he's not in the top three
there is also shocking right um normally and maybe
it was that weird french game where they played
the poison pawn and nobody could guess the moves
like or maybe it was that bullet game where they
missed checkmate so you know the fans were saying
hey there's check minute one that's gotta be the
move but it wasn't played or or poor guessers when
you're guessing better than super grand masters
you can't be too upset um all right well this
has been it's been a lot of fun we apologize to
the fans for for no interviews not that not the
normal run of show to speak production here but
we had a great day regardless it was a super fun
match and we have a great one ahead tomorrow with
ikara nakamura taking on hike marty rossian so
uh make sure you tune in then we will see you
all for my partner the one and only mr chess
grandmaster robert hess the team working hard
here all of all of those who make these events
amazing our moderators and our staff working
hard behind the scenes we appreciate you and
we will see you tomorrow for another speed chess
championship match until then good night everybody
you